[MUSIC PLAYING]
KAISER: Welcome family and
friends of the MIT graduating
Class of 2004.
[APPLAUSE]
I am speaking to you up here
at the head of the commencement
stand.
Can you all see me?
I'll wave.
Can you see me?
Great.
Hello.
I think our picture is also
on the big television screen
over there, the jumbotron.
My name is Jay Kaiser, and I'm
an emeritus professor at MIT.
And this is what
emeritus professors do.
We entertain you
until your graduates
come into this beautiful court.
I'm joined by my colleague
Warren Seamans, who,
for 32 years, was
associated with MIT
and known, most of all, as
director of the MIT Museum.
There's no one at MIT who
knows more about MIT lore
and history than Warren.
We will be visiting with
you for the next hour or so
as we await the arrival
of the guests of honor--
your children.
They are currently gathering
in the Johnson Athletic Center
on the west side of the
campus, and they should
be joining us at about 9:50.
If you take a look
at the screen,
you can see them over in
the Johnson Athletic Center
now through the
magic of television.
It is now 8:18.
Please synchronize your watches.
During this time, we will also
have some video pieces to show.
So make sure that you have
a good view of the screen.
And we'll share with you
a variety of perspectives
of the MIT experience
that the students had
when they were here.
This is a gorgeous day.
Rarely has there been
a day when I could say,
look up in the sky, and
you will not see a cloud.
It's amazing.
We have really been blessed
with this beautiful day,
and it's a beautiful
day for us and for you.
We've been dodging rain.
It rained yesterday.
It rained the day before.
But no rain today, and that
makes this commencement
setting a special one.
The court has a rich
and interesting history.
And as I said,
there are few people
who know more about that
history than my colleague Warren
Seamans, who will tell you
a little bit about the place
you're now sitting in.
Warren?
SEAMANS: Welcome,
welcome, welcome.
It is a great pleasure for me
to be here again this year.
I think it's important
to know a little bit
about this holy center of MIT.
88 years ago, in 1916,
this was dedicated
when this new campus was built
and dedicated June of 1916.
Since that time, it has served
as really the Institute's
public living room--
everything from
graduation commencement
ceremonies through the
inauguration of new presidents
to a lot of social
activities, some of which
you will see on our
video screens today.
Over the years, it has
served as a meeting place.
Traditionally, over the
history of the place,
the first actual meeting of
the freshmen class coming in
was held here in--
it was known as the Great Court.
In 1974, it was
renamed Killian Court
after James Rhyne
Killian, who had just
stepped down as chairman
of the MIT Corporation.
This has served in many other
ways as a center for MIT life.
In 1930, June 6 of
1930, Karl Compton
was inaugurated
president in this locale.
At that day, in
comparison to today,
it was 106 here in
the Killian Court.
It's also interesting to note
that the ashes of at least
two MIT presidents have
been sprinkled or spread
in to the Great Court.
So it is truly a
significant center of MIT.
I thought it would
be interesting,
since we are here, to take
a look at the object that's
directly behind us on
the speaker's podium.
That's the great seal of MIT.
You will notice
from looking at it
that it has a lot of
significance to the group
meeting today.
1861 is the day of the actual
signing of the MIT charter.
That would be 134 years--
33 years ago--
143 years ago, and this has been
always part of the MIT story.
Over the years, they've tried
to upgrade it, to change it,
but it always comes back to
use of the original MIT seal.
"Mens et Manus,"
"Mind and Hand,"
are opposed to the
Science and [AUDIO OUT]
artist and the scientist.
And Science and Arts are
repeated on the chapters--
on the spines of the books that
are on the mantle of learning.
So you'll get an idea
of this, and you'll
see this used in a
lot of other places.
With that, I'll
turn back to Jay.
KAISER: If you look
behind you, you'll
see a glorious cityscape.
It's one of the most beautiful,
I think, in the United States.
And so be sure you take
a moment at some time
to look at the cities--
the view of the city from
the Killian Court here.
In the beginning when
MIT was designed,
I believe this court actually
went all the way down
to the river, and you could
actually dock at the end there.
Now, of course, Memorial
Drive is a major thoroughfare.
Well, as Warren said, the
ashes of two presidents
have been scattered here.
So I'd like to ask you to
be careful where you walk.
And while you're
doing that, we're
going to roll our first tape.
This court provides
many activities--
a place for many
activities at MIT.
And occasionally it's
used as a flight test site
for our robotic helicopter
developed by students at MIT.
If you'll take a look
at the jumbotron,
we'll show you video of
what that looked like.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This project is to demonstrate
what automatic [INAUDIBLE]
maneuvering for
an aerial vehicle.
- In the Killian Court, we
have done a flight in so-called
control augmentation system,
where the pilot gives very
high-level commands,
for example,
go forward or go sideways
or turn, go slightly higher,
slightly lower.
The pilot doesn't
have to take care
of stabilization of the system.
That's done by automatic
control system.
- The vehicle we
did not work on.
We purchased a vehicle directly
from a miniature aircraft.
- Nice.
- We picked this machine
because it's very cheap.
It's mass manufactured,
and we could outfit it
with our own electronics
very quickly.
- So this is our ground station.
It's a very old laptop,
about three years old.
It's around [INAUDIBLE] time
[? for ?] rating system.
And it gets the data from the
helicopter about the sensors
and the state--
attitude, velocities,
altitude, and everything else.
And the ground station operator
monitors that all of sensors
are doing fine.
And then we take all
this data, we analyze it.
We record the trajectories
of acrobatic maneuvers
that Roger has performed, and
we designed the controllers
that follows this trajectory.
- So what happens is we use
filtering technologies in order
to synthesize this information
into a complete and accurate
estimate of where the helicopter
is and what's it's doing.
- Now, previously on
a small rotorcraft,
and larger rotorcraft as
well, when they were flown
autonomously, have been
flying very non-aggressive
trajectories.
And what we have contributed
is autonomous aggressive
maneuvering.
So we were able to design
the control laws that
allow us to perform an aerobatic
maneuver completely hands-off.
- The applications could
include news gathering,
so gathering video footage
of hard-to-explore areas,
top of mountains, top of
volcanoes, fire situations,
any environment which is
very [? computated, ?] very
contrived, and they require
[INAUDIBLE] machines
to operate.
- You can also use it for
a number of [INAUDIBLE]
applications, for example,
[INAUDIBLE] and [? pursuit. ?]
- There's an aesthetic
component to our research,
which is to make such machines
as graceful as possible.
What we would want is that
this machine eventually
behaves and flies as well,
if not better, than a bird.
- Altitude, altitude.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
KAISER: Now, that
tape that you just saw
was the work of Eric
Feron, and his office
is in the new MIT Stata Center.
Hi.
And I met him recently.
That's one of the great
things about the center.
It's very easy for people
to meet one another.
And one of the things that
the tape didn't show you
was that Eric has this
ability to write backwards.
He can write backwards
with either hand.
Now, you might say, what
good is that ability?
Well, his office
has a glass door.
And if you write
backwards on the inside,
you can read it right
side up on the other side.
And so that's what he does.
He wrote his name and his office
backwards in the Stata Center.
The students being
honored today have
been at MIT during a period
of unprecedented growth
in our student life
and learning programs,
resulting in the construction
of new dorms, new classrooms,
and a beautiful new
athletic center.
For people like Warren and me,
who have been at MIT for, well,
30, 40 years, MIT
is really taking
on a completely new
look, and we hope you'll
get a chance to enjoy that.
The new dormitories, the
new athletic center, even
the Stata Center itself
has just opened up.
It all gives-- it's just MIT
doesn't look the same anymore.
We recently produced a series
of short video retrospectives
where students talk
about the MIT experience
outside of their classrooms
and laboratories.
And if you'll watch the
humongous-tron behind us,
you'll catch a glimpse--
you may catch a glimpse
of one of your children.
So here we go.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - "THE ENGINEERS'
DRINKING SONG"]
(SINGING) We are, we
are, we are, we are,
we are the engineers.
[INAUDIBLE] We can, we
can, we can, we can.
- There's clubs for everything.
And people are doing it, and
MIT gives them money for it.
And there's so much to do
here, which I did not think.
I thought everybody would just
be holed away in their lab
somewhere.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- They let you have a whole
diverse group of opportunities
for you to kind of
follow, and you can easily
transition from one to another.
- The expectations of today's
students are different.
They expect more of
their universities
than I think the
generation of students
maybe 20 or 30 years ago.
They expect their universities
to provide a range of services
and opportunities, which many
universities didn't provide
30 years ago when I came here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I think it helps
keep them sharp.
I think it contributes
to the mental health.
It's a great way
to blow off steam
from the intense
classroom experience
and then the sheer
intensity of the place.
That hasn't changed either,
in fact, if anything,
it's more intense.
So I think it's just
a key to leading
a very well-balanced life.
And gee, they have a lot
of interests nowadays too.
- A lot of students
who come to MIT
were very involved in
things in high school.
I held several leadership
positions in tons of clubs,
and I wanted to continue
that while I was here.
Because for me,
learning isn't just
about doing the curricular
aspect of things,
like just learning biology
or learning about cells.
It's about learning
how to be a leader,
how to be a better
person through activities
that you're in.
And you gain a lot of skills
from working with people
and learning from
people as well.
- Mr. Worthing and I are
engaged to be married.
- Pardon me.
- Because MIT did
have all of it,
I definitely thought that
it was the place for me.
- We've come to understand
that the full experience
for the student really needs to
have this sense of community.
And a community means what
happens in residential groups?
What happens in sports with
intramural and formal sports
events and collegiate
sports events?
What happens in music groups?
What happens day to day as
students work with each other
and with the faculty?
- There are only so many things
you can learn in the classroom.
And I've been here for
three and a half years now,
and definitely the
most I've gotten out
of my college experience
has not been things
I've learned in the classroom.
It's definitely been
the opportunities
I've had outside of it.
- These are going to
be the future leaders,
someone who is able to do
the work at MIT and who are
top-level athletes,
musicians, drama stars.
Whatever their passion is,
we want to find the best.
And it's not mutually
exclusive with the academics.
(SINGING) Don't
you lose your head.
- It's been something that's
given me a lot personally,
and I feel something that's
going to give a lot back
to the community
at MIT and the rest
of the world in the future.
- I think the
current MIT student
comes out and sees a much
wider range of opportunities.
They will lead companies.
They will lead groups
within companies.
They will go to government,
to nonprofit organizations.
And all the skills they acquire,
not just in the classroom,
but in the full community
life of being an MIT student,
will be a tremendous
value to them.
(SINGING) Yes, we
are, yes we are.
We are the engine--
we are, we are, we are,
we are the engineers.
[END PLAYBACK]
KAISER: Yep.
All right, this is the
part of the program where
we'd like to meet some of you.
And we thought it
might be fun to talk
to those of you who have come
from the farthest distance.
So if you think you've
come the longest
distance for this
graduation, come up to us.
We're standing right
over here by the screen.
You can all see me.
Come up, and we'll talk to
you about where you're from.
So those of you who have
come the longest distance.
Now, remember, longest
distance is not London.
That's just, I mean, London,
just around the corner.
And not Hoboken.
Hoboken just seems far.
Ah, here's somebody.
Good, hi.
And let's have some others.
If you think you've come
the longest distance, please
come here.
In the meantime,
let's check in and see
how the students are doing over
in the Johnson Athletic Center.
Hi, can you hear me over there?
You can hear me?
Yes, can we work
on the sound there,
because I can't quite hear you.
JK: Mike, they can't hear me.
You want me to go louder?
KAISER: Yeah, that's good.
[INAUDIBLE]
JK: All righty.
KAISER: That's good.
What's your name?
JK: JK.
KAISER: JK?
JK: Yep.
KAISER: That's my initials--
Jay Kaiser.
JK: [LAUGHS]
KAISER: What do you know,
Where are you from, JK?
JK: I'm from India, but I
grew up in the Middle East.
KAISER: And where
did you grow up?
JK: In Muscat, the
Sultanate of Oman.
KAISER: So how many
languages do you speak?
JK: Fluently, or languages
I assume I speak?
KAISER: Languages in which you
could conduct a conversation.
JK: Four.
KAISER: And what are they?
JK: English, Hindi,
Tamil, [INAUDIBLE]..
KAISER: Amazing.
That's wonderful.
And what did you major in?
What was your major?
JK: Aero/astro.
KAISER: And do you have a job?
JK: Yep, I'm on staff at MIT.
KAISER: Wow.
Do you have a place to live?
JK: Yep, 1010 Mass Ave. My folks
are in the audience right now.
KAISER: Oh, where
are your folks?
Raise your hand.
Are your folks here?
JK: Yep.
KAISER: Where are they?
JK: I got--
KAISER: Boy, you've
got a lot of folks.
JK: [LAUGHS]
KAISER: Where are they?
Oh, there they are.
JK, they're waiting for you.
JK: I know, I know.
Hang on, let me introduce you
to some people who are here.
KAISER: Terrific, please.
PRETORIUS: Hi, I'm [? Jakob ?]
Pretorius from South Africa.
JK: Where are you
from in South Africa?
PRETORIUS: [INAUDIBLE].
JK: South Africa?
PRETORIUS: Johannesburg.
KAISER: I've been
to Johannesburg.
JK: He's been to Johannesburg.
PRETORIUS: Oh, he has?
KAISER: Yeah.
Where do you-- let's
see, jacaranda.
That's right, jacaranda
trees grow in [INAUDIBLE]..
PRETORIUS: Yeah, very nice.
But Pretoria is actually the
city for jacaranda trees.
KAISER: Yeah, I've been to
Pretoria too, nice town.
JK: He's been to
Pretoria as well.
KAISER: And your name
is, what, [? Jakob? ?]
JK: [? Jakob? ?]
PRETORIUS: Yes.
KAISER: And are
your parents here?
PRETORIUS: They should
be there, and my wife
should be on stage too.
KAISER: You're married?
JK: You're married?
PRETORIUS: Yes.
KAISER: Good for you.
You look like you're 16.
PRETORIUS: I'm not prepared to
disclose that information right
now, thanks.
KAISER: I don't blame you.
All right, it's nice
talking to you guys.
We'll come back to
you in a few minutes.
But we're going to roll
another tape over here
to entertain your parents.
JK: All right, cheers.
KAISER: Take care.
See you, JK.
When I got a [INAUDIBLE],,
I'll come to you.
When the Class of
2004 were sophomores,
a good number of them took MIT's
renowned engineering course
2.007.
This is the much emulated
course where students design,
engineer, and build
a machine that
accomplishes a specific task.
All this hard work culminates
in an end-of-semester contest,
which is the big event at MIT.
At this contest, students
compete head to head
in MIT's most exciting
spectator sport.
We offer you a look at
some of the participants
and their clever machines.
You might recognize
your graduate
as they appeared when they were
hard at work as sophomores.
2.007.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- 3, 2, 1, go!
- It's time again for the
granddaddy of all the student
engineering contests--
the annual battle of machines
built by sophomores at MIT.
- And now comes the fun
part-- calling my mom.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- This year's contest,
hatched six months earlier,
involves a teeter-totter beam
and a swinging 8-pound ball.
The challenge is
to build a machine
that starts out
sitting on the beam
and that after
exactly 45 seconds
has managed to tilt
its side of the beam
down working against an opponent
trying to do the same thing.
There's a 10-pound weight limit
for each machine and a box
of parts to make it from.
- There are a bunch of
structural materials
that they can--
- Each of the 100-plus
students in the contest,
which is actually a course
in mechanical engineering,
gets an identical kit of stuff,
including several electric
motors from home power tools,
as well as things that seem like
mechanical leftovers.
What would you do with this?
- Nobody in the class
knows what that is.
[LAUGHTER]
- We had a--
- So nobody-- you don't
know what this is?
- No one knows how
they're going to use it.
- Usually, people just do this--
pop it in and take the motor
and do something with the
motor and then toss that back
in there.
What it is good for is--
- It is a mistake
to toss that away?
After several weeks of
brainstorming and designing
their machines on
paper and computer,
the class sets to work
manufacturing them.
After 14 weeks of design,
construction, and testing,
the machines faced
one last hurdle.
- Fit it in the box
however you can get it in.
- Yeah.
- To qualify for the
contest, every machine
must fit within the
box its parts came in.
- Did that go straight?
- Yeah, there.
- All right.
Put the lid on, please.
- Woo-hoo.
- Before an expectant crowd
at MIT's ice hockey arena--
- 2, 1, go!
- --Nick Martin's machine,
flawless in tests,
doesn't give him
his money's worth.
[INAUDIBLE]
- It fell over.
That was of depressing.
I'd never seen it before.
And I tested it, ran it.
But I guess that's what
engineering is all about.
- The first semifinal,
and now it's
Will Lark's turn to face
Will DelHagen's jack.
Almost before the car has
even jumped off the beam,
the jack is hoisting it up.
All Will DelHagen has to
do is stand by and watch
as Will Lark's car desperately
tries to hook around the jack
and yank it away.
[CHEERING]
- 4, 3, 2, 1.
- For Will Lark, it's
the end of a great run.
- That's my only way I
could've gotten it was
was trying to mess him up, so.
- 3, 2, go.
- The second semifinal.
It's Alex [? Jacobson's ?]
mobile jack
against a simple extender
that has quietly made it
through round after around.
For a moment, it looks like
Alex has gotten trapped
by the corner, but then--
so for the finals, it's mobile
jack against mobile jack.
- There was a lot of
things I didn't get
done that I wanted to get done.
But everything I needed,
I guess, I finished, so.
- We tracked Alex down
behind the scenes,
where it turned out he'd
been conspiring with Will.
Good friends who have
been comparing notes ever
since the class
began, Will and Alex
now plan a final collaboration.
Carefully choreographed,
the two robots
jack the whole apparatus
an inch off the ground
with the beam dead level.
- Doghouse.
- The result is a tie.
- Double win?
- Double win.
Double win.
- Or, in MIT speak,
a double win.
- Double win.
- This has never
ever happened before.
And we're so happy
it did, because we
like doing things different.
- Double win.
[END PLAYBACK]
SEAMANS: Scientific American--
the clip you've just seen
is credited to Scientific
American Frontiers.
The 2.007 contest remains MIT's
most widely attended spectator
event.
But a lack of
spectators does not
prevent MIT students from
participating in athletics.
In fact, it is not
widely known, but MIT
fields more NCAA athletic
teams than any other school
in the country, with
the possible exception
of that other
school up the river.
As this video
illustrates, MIT students
don't sit in the stands.
They participate.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- MIT sponsors a uniquely
expansive athletic department
which features 25
intercollegiate sports, 40 club
sport offerings, and 42
intercollegiate athletic
programs.
- Athletics are part of this
notion of building a community
and building a complete
individual's education.
- I certainly feel more
well rounded because of it.
I feel that I've had the chance
to excel in different aspects
of my life.
- MIT has the largest number
of academic All-Americans
in the country, with 114 since
the program began in 1980.
I think it showcases
that our kids are
doing exceptionally
well in the classroom
as well as on the field.
- At the beginning
of each season,
the football coach says,
gentlemen, the first priority
for you is going to
be your academics.
Second priority is
going to be football.
And if your list
doesn't look like this,
then you shouldn't
be in this room.
- Nearly 60% of
our undergraduates
compete in organized sports
at some level on campus.
- It's a good thing because
I met a lot of people
that I wouldn't
have met otherwise,
who I would see afterwards.
And I'm like, oh,
you're on my IM team.
So how's it going?
How's your research?
- They don't exist
for themselves.
They don't exist for the alumni
to make the alumni feel good.
We have them
because they're part
of the educational experience.
- [INAUDIBLE]
Out and into the water, down.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The crew boat
itself, a 70-foot boat,
is a micromanaged
system in and of itself.
You got the administrator
in your coxswain.
And then you've got
your powerhouse.
You've got your stroke, who is
your leader of your powerhouse.
And then you've got
your 4 and 5 seats
who are the peak of your boat.
And then you've got your
bow, who kind of guides
you along in the little
directions left and right.
And so together you work as
a team to the common goal.
- They learn incredible amounts
about leadership, teamwork,
sportsmanship, and
courage, the willingness
to take risks and push
their abilities beyond what
they think they can achieve.
- I have learned to
push myself during races
and during practices so
hard and commit myself
to a certain goal
unequivocally and in a way
that I never had before.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The MIT I knew in the '60s
and early '70s had a proper
emphasis on athletics and a
tremendous diversity of sports
and really emphasized
participation.
That part hasn't changed.
But what's happened is
there is even a greater
variety of sports today.
- If MIT doesn't have
something, be it a club
or an organization or a sport,
if two people want to do it,
they'll let you organize
it, and you can have it.
It's up to the individual,
but MIT will embrace that.
- It always has been in
the past and always will
be about opportunity for all.
- One of the things that
I think is particularly
striking about the
athletic program at MIT
is the emphasis on
participation in sports
rather than spectator sports.
You don't see the
whole campus coming out
to watch the football game
on a Saturday afternoon
like you might find on
some college campuses.
But you do see an
incredible number
of students that are engaged.
Currently, about
20% of the students
are involved in a varsity sport.
About 80% of the students are
involved in intramural sports.
And 100% of the
undergraduates are
involved in the physical
education program.
- So it really lets students
pursue their interests,
whether they pursue them as
an extracurricular activity
through their school previously
or whether it's something
brand-new.
- We've been able to make
major investments in facilities
and support services
that have enhanced
an already vital program.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The biggest single change has
been the opening of the Zesiger
Center.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The Z Center.
That thing's just
beautiful, man.
- It just seemed like the
MIT campus became healthier
because people were
more willing to work out
because there were more
facilities and they were nicer.
- The new facilities
have been made possible
because there was a
vision on the part of MIT,
but then the
facilities could not
have been created without the
financial support of the alums,
who have come forth
to say, yes, we
recognize that that is
an important priority,
and we want to be
able to support it.
- You'll be in there
lifting weights,
and your professor
will be in there
lifting weights
also or something,
and you'll say hi to him.
And just little things like
that, seeing people outside
of the classroom and interacting
not in an academic way,
I think, really helps
build the community.
- It's not just
about the classroom
or just about the
laboratory, but it's
about growing as a person.
And part of that is
working with other students
or participating in sports
or other sort of events,
the arts, all of which
will carry forward
into their future lives.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
KAISER: If you count Europe
and Asia as a single continent,
there are six
continents in the world,
and we have three of
them represented here.
We have the man who has come
the farthest, from Perth,
Australia, is Tan.
Raise your hand, Tan.
He spent, what, 25
hours on the plane.
TAN: 25 hours flying [INAUDIBLE]
from Perth to Boston.
KAISER: And you have--
how many children
are graduating?
TAN: I got one child
who's graduating now, yep,
and she's in the Sloan
School of Management.
KAISER: Sloan School
of Management.
And the next farthest
comes from Bombay, India.
Her name is Amita Parekh.
PAREKH: Hi.
KAISER: [INAUDIBLE]
PAREKH: One.
He's graduating from the
Sloan School of Management,
and I'm very proud.
KAISER: Two comments,
one graduate school.
Our next comes from Buenos
Aires, Argentina, Hugo Batales.
And your child?
BATALES: My child is
Alexander Batales.
He's [INAUDIBLE] in economics.
KAISER: In economics.
BATALES: Economics.
KAISER: And is he going to
go back to Buenos Aires?
BATALES: No, I think he
thinks to continue study
in the school.
KAISER: Very good.
And then finally, from Beirut,
Lebanon, Michelle and Patricia
Nabti.
NABTI: Hello.
Yes, our daughter
is Jumana Nabti
and she's getting two masters,
one in urban planning,
one in transportation.
KAISER: Wow, that's wonderful.
So tell me, Tan, since
you've come the farthest,
is this your first time you've
been to the United States?
TAN: No, I've been here a few
times, and I like America.
KAISER: Well, that's a relief.
[LAUGHTER]
It's good to hear that.
I like Australia.
And Hugo, is this
your first time?
BATALES: No, I came many times.
Actually, I was married
with an American woman,
and we got three kids, two
born in Buenos Aries and one
born in the States.
KAISER: And what do you do?
BATALES: I have an industry.
I make fire extinguishers
in Argentina.
KAISER: You make
fire extinguishers.
Would you give the
people here a deal?
[LAUGHTER]
Hugo says, if there's anybody
out there needs a fire
extinguisher, see him.
Tan, what do you do?
TAN: I'm a businessman.
I make cakes.
KAISER: You make what?
TAN: Cheesecakes.
AUDIENCE: Mm, cheesecake.
KAISER: All right, now
Tan is a friend of mine.
NABTI: He is my friend too.
KAISER: And what about you?
What do you do?
PAREKH: I work in a bank
in India, a private bank.
KAISER: I just
changed allegiances.
Michelle and Patricia,
what do you do?
NABTI: Yes.
Well, I established
a volunteer center
for the country of Lebanon.
So the last six years
that's what I've been doing.
KAISER: And you?
NABTI: I spent a career
at the Hoover Institution
on War, Revolution, and
Peace at Stanford University
as Middle East area specialist.
KAISER: So your area of
specialty is Middle East.
NABTI: Modern Middle East.
KAISER: So it's your fault.
NABTI: Yes.
KAISER: All right.
So what we got to do here is
break out a little cheesecake
and break out a little fire
extinguisher and have fun.
Thank you very much, folks.
It's really been marvelous.
AUDIENCE: Oh, wait.
Here comes a proud mother.
KAISER: OK, we've got this--
we've got to [INAUDIBLE]
people [INAUDIBLE]..
All right.
Now, I want-- oh, we
have somebody else here?
Oh, where are you from?
PARENT: I am coming
from Chennai.
PARENT: India.
And I'm mother of
JK, who just talk.
KAISER: Oh, very good.
Well, is Chennai
farther than Bombay?
PARENT: Yes.
KAISER: JK, your
parents are here.
They want to know
what you're up to.
Thank you very much, folks.
It's really been wonderful.
Thank you very much.
Let's give them a big hand.
[APPLAUSE]
He's got two.
Hang on just a second.
Now then, I would like to
invite all those families who
have the most MIT
degrees back to back.
In other words, if you have
a child and you went to MIT
and your grandfather went to
MIT and your great-grandfather,
come on up.
In the meantime, Killian
Court is not only
the setting for MIT's grand
commencement ceremony,
but it's a favorite setting
for relaxation and recreation.
This is something very special.
Killian Court has also
become a preferred hunting
ground for MIT's resident
red-tailed hawks.
Apparently, a number of
nesting pairs of hawks
have decided, as many of
you did four years ago,
that MIT is a great environment
for maturation and learning.
We recently had the pleasure,
due to their choice of nest
location, to witness up close a
four-week process in which two
down-covered chicks grew
into fledglings that
left the nest just last week.
We offer this
retrospective as we
wait for your prospective
fledglings to arrive.
Take a look at the
humongous-tron.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- These baby chicks were
hatched on April 9 in a tree
just across the street
from the Student Center.
During the week of April 19,
MIT's in-house video production
department set up a video camera
and shared these images 24/7
throughout the Institute
via MIT's cable TV system.
The following week, we began
sharing the development
of these chicks with the world
via a 12-hour per day webcast.
We were amazed at how
quickly they grew.
Many viewers wrote
to tell us that they
had detected visible
growth within a single day.
Not unlike the graduates we
honor today when they were just
babies, the single mission of
these youngsters was to be fed
and to sleep.
The parent hawks constantly
doted on the chicks,
delivering a nonstop assortment
of Cambridge-area prey.
Their first tentative
steps resulted
in the inevitable
stumble and header.
The parent hawks continued
to fortify the nest
as the babies grew.
These chicks also
experience some
of the same character-building
New England weather
that your children have been
exposed to these past years.
At different times,
the outstretched wings
of the mother
protected the babies
from a 2-inch dusting of snow
or from several downpours.
And through it all, the chicks
ate and grew and ate some more.
During their sophomore period,
the down gave way in places
to feathers, and
the now juveniles
became more adventurous.
More aggressive attempts
at negotiating the nest
earned similar results--
a face plant.
But as the footing became
surer and the balance improved,
it was time to
stretch those wings
and exercise those muscles.
Now, as juniors, these
students were learning
as much as they could handle.
Mother explained that
the food they ate
didn't just grow on trees.
Lessons were provided in
the value of the hunt.
And as the last bits of
down were preened away
and feathers continued to grow,
the youngsters enthusiastically
tested their abilities
at defying gravity.
As is usually the case,
one of the siblings
was far more the
risk-taker, the trailblazer.
Though only separated by
perhaps a day at birth,
it was clear that
one of the siblings
was far more anxious to
explore life outside the nest.
Finally, graduation
week had arrived.
And just a week ago Tuesday,
the more precocious sibling,
who we named Kitty Hawk,
jumped from the nest
and glided safely
to the other side
of Mass Ave., landing on
a bicycle rack in front
of the Student Center.
MIT Campus Police, aided
by a number of onlookers,
secured the area,
while the fledgling
practiced take-offs
and landings by flying
from handlebar to handlebar.
Over the next few
hours, Kitty Hawk
made its way, seemingly
a branch at a time,
up a nearby evergreen
to an elevation where
it gained enough confidence to
attempt a return flight back
to the nest, encouraged
by cries from its mother.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Kitty Hawk provided
encouragement
to the less daring
sibling, Mitzi,
also known as Chicken Hawk.
But Mitzi wasn't quite ready.
Days passed, and Mitzi, although
the spirit seemed willing,
couldn't bring himself to
venture beyond the nest.
We speculated that yet
another torrential downpour
might provide the
necessary incentive,
but Mitzi toughed it out.
Food continued to be
provided, and he now
had a room all to himself.
Why leave?
Parental and sibling
encouragement
continued, to where last
Friday Mitzi jumped,
flew to the highest
point in the tree,
and looked like he was ready.
A gust of wind and
a flurry of wings,
and the less than gracious
hawk stumbled downward--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
--luckily landing
in the nest below.
Failure breeds success,
and Mitzi undoubtedly
learned from that
failed attempt.
The very next morning,
Saturday, 5:00 AM, Mitzi
took his maiden flight.
Perhaps he was waiting
for a smaller audience
or for the sun to finally shine.
But later that day,
he and Kitty Hawk
were spotted together on the
highest ledge of the Student
Center and have
since been spotted
on ledges and windowsills
throughout the Institute.
You may even see them
flying about today.
This is indeed a place
where the young learn
while they mature
and test their limits
and learn from their
mistakes and finally
leave, with confidence and a
sense of great accomplishment
to stretch their wings and
explore new horizons where
possibilities are boundless.
We wish them the very best.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
KAISER: Right now we're going
to go back over to the Johnson
Athletic Center to
interview your children
and see who we've got.
So take a look at the screen,
and I'll see who I can see.
Who have you got over there?
LEE: How are you doing?
KAISER: Pretty good.
What's your name?
LEE: My name is Kenny Lee.
I'm class of '04, Sloan School.
KAISER: Oh, yeah.
OK, Kenny.
Everybody's Sloan School.
But tell me, who are
the people around you?
LEE: These are my
best friends at MIT.
I'm going to let them
introduce themselves.
KAISER: Yeah, please do.
GOLDMAN: My name
is Megan Goldman.
I am class of 2004,
undergraduate.
KIM: Mark Kim,
class of 2004, MBA.
Shout out to all those
on the West Coast.
Let's hear a cheer.
BUTLER: Hi, I'm Katie Butler.
I'm an [INAUDIBLE] EECS of 2004.
Whoo!
LEE: Nice.
[? MABLEY: ?] Hi, I'm Mandy
[? Mabley, ?] class of 2004,
Sloan.
Hi, mom, dad,
Scotty, Kelly, Molly.
LEE: Hi, my name's David
Lee, class of 2004 at Sloan,
from Fairfax, Virginia.
What's up, mom, dad?
KAISER: So tell me, what's
your name again, tell me?
LEE: Kenny.
KAISER: Kenny, did you meet
all of these guys at MIT?
You're at Sloan School, right?
LEE: That's correct.
KAISER: Did they
all live with you
or were you in the same dorm?
LEE: Part of it--
they want to know if we
were all in the same dorm,
did we live together?
BUTLER: Nope.
LEE: So there's a few of us
from the Sloan School here.
We all took the same classes,
lived in the MIT graduate
dorms.
BUTLER: Some of us
live off campus.
GOLDMAN: I'm at Sydney Pacific.
Hi mom and dad and
Jan and Donnie.
KAISER: This is management.
Tell me, will you
guys-- do you think
you'll be able to keep in
contact with one another
after you've graduated?
LEE: Do you think we'll be
able to keep contact with one
another after we graduate?
LEE: Oh, I definitely think
we're going to stay in contact.
I think one of the big things
from MIT that I think I'll take
was the networking,
all the great friends
we made while we been here.
KAISER: How about the others?
What do you think?
MABLEY: Absolutely.
The friendships will
definitely last a lifetime.
KAISER: That's marvelous.
MABLEY: We'll stay in touch.
BUTLER: We'll definitely
stay in touch, mostly
because a lot of people are
moving to California, like me,
yeah.
KIM: I think the
great thing about MIT
are all the great
people that you meet.
So definitely stay in touch.
A lot of these people will be
my lifelong friends, especially
Megan and Katie here.
KAISER: All right.
GOLDMAN: Yes, it's been very
nice meeting Mark today.
KAISER: All right.
GOLDMAN: But I definitely
will stay in touch
with all of my friends.
KAISER: OK, Kenny?
LEE: Yeah, go ahead.
KAISER: I want you to, on
three, I'd like you to have you
and all of your friends
wave to all of their friends
and parents here
in Killian Court.
1--
LEE: Well, actually,
can I just interrupt?
We've been working on a move
for the past three days--
KAISER: Excellent, let's do it.
LEE: --perfecting it.
On the count of three,
we're going to do our move.
Is everyone ready?
KAISER: Everybody,
look at the screen.
LEE: We're kind of
limbered up here.
All right, you
give us the count.
KAISER: A 1.
LEE: 1.
KAISER: 2.
LEE: 2.
KAISER: 3.
LEE: 3.
Hey.
ALL: Yay.
LEE: Love you.
KAISER: Great, Kenny.
That's the MIT wave.
LEE: Thank you.
KAISER: Wow, that looks
like they're having
a very good time over there.
I wonder if they'll
ever come over here.
MIT has just recently
celebrated the completion
of the long-awaited
Ray and Maria Stata
Center, a Frank
Gehry-designed building that
is the home to the Computer
Science and Artificial
Intelligence Laboratories, the
lab for Information and Design
Systems, and the Departments
of Linguistics and Philosophy.
I'm a member of the Department
of Linguistics and Philosophy,
and I have an office
in the Stata Building.
If you haven't seen
it, you must go see it.
It's on Vassar Street, and it's
that very odd-shaped-looking
building.
None of the lines are
straight up and down.
They're all sort of at angles.
In fact, the worse
fear of the architect
is that there will
be an earthquake
and straighten the building.
So we're going to see
a video tape that's
going to compress
into a few moments
the building of this
remarkable edifice.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - "TAKE FIVE"]
[APPLAUSE]
- I'm sure that the legacy of
the great accomplishments that
were born in Building 20 that
you've all heard about here
today are going to be preserved
and extended and enhanced
in this new space that will
replace the time-honored
building.
- We are thrilled that we
will be able to move there,
and our generations of students
and researchers to come
will be able to
continue to innovate
and help us lead better lives.
- This piece of land in
this part of the campus
will mark the information
science, cognitive science,
and biology parts that will
drive much of our economy
and much of our knowledge
in this next century.
- We have the best faculty
and the best students.
And soon they will have
the group of buildings
of the quality they deserve.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- This is also a building
that pushes the edge of design
and construction technology.
It's a building that
was built entirely
from a three-dimensional
digital model.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- One of the things that we
really wanted from the start
was room to think, and
this literally gives us
plenty of room to think.
There's light.
There's air.
- It's like an ecosystem.
It has everything we need.
- I love it.
It's like living in a diorama.
- It's made me use
my imagination,
and I think that's
what it's all about.
- The transition from the inside
world to the outside world
is gradual, and
there seems to be
a union between the
inside and the outside.
- Just amazing
space, amazing space.
You see, we have the two
floors here, the first floor,
the second floor.
Each slab is organized that way.
- The space is really original.
And I really like the fact
that a lot of the neighborhood
organized around open
spaces that really encourage
collaboration and
informal meeting,
just bumping into each other.
- I thought it was
rather traditional.
- I love the fact that I
don't have to go outside
to get to the main campus.
- I was really excited to see
how beautiful the space is.
It's really just
these lofted ceilings
and a lot of community areas.
- There was always a community,
but it was a community
in spite of the architecture.
Here we have a community
abetted by the architecture.
- What I have is a view
not of Boston or Harvard,
but a view looking
right into the building.
So I get to see
Frank Gehry every day
as I look out of my
window, and I like that.
- Stata is a building
that's bubbling over
with the joy of invention, the
pleasure of space and light,
the satisfaction of
making something well,
and the enjoyment
of being members
of a vital, argumentative,
bursting with ideas community.
This is a building that
combines superb technology
with humanity and fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
KAISER: We are about to
interview the MIT generations.
But before we do, I'd like
to make a brief announcement.
The MIT News Office
has produced a brochure
that outlines the
accomplishments of Chuck Vest's
administration
and career at MIT.
That brochure is available
at the tent behind you,
and you can pick it
up any time you like.
It's a very
interesting brochure,
and it picks up every one
of the important points
of Chuck's career,
which, as you know,
will come to an end as
president with this commencement
after having been president
for 13 and 1/2 years.
So the MIT News Office has made
that available to all of you.
Now we have behind me the
generational MIT group.
So we're going to first
start with you, ma'am.
What is your name?
[? LAPIN: ?] Marian [? Lapin. ?]
KAISER: And tell us
how many generations?
[? LAPIN: ?] We have three
generations in my family--
my husband class of 1935,
my son class of '64,
and now my grandson, who's
getting his master's in 2004.
KAISER: That's unbelievable.
Your husband was class of '35?
[? LAPIN: ?] Yes, he was an
electrical engineer, and he
worked for RCA for many years.
KAISER: That was
the year I was born.
May I ask how old you are?
[? LAPIN: ?] Yes, 91.
KAISER: How about that?
May I have this dance?
[? LAPIN: ?] I'd
rather play tennis.
KAISER: Do you play tennis now?
[? LAPIN: ?] Yes, I do, I
do, several times a week,
indoors in the winter,
outdoors in the summer.
KAISER: Is that
what you attribute
your good health and--
[? LAPIN: ?] Yes.
KAISER: --to tennis?
KAISER: All right,
everybody, take up tennis.
And this man here is her son.
[? LAPIN: ?] But not the
one that went to MIT.
KAISER: Yes, he went to Penn.
That's Okay, Penn's
good, Penn's good.
And you, ma'am?
KELLER: Hi, I'm Margie
Keller, and I'm here
with my husband Rob Keller.
Our daughter Karen Keller
is graduating in 2004.
I graduated in 1968 in physics.
My husband graduated in 1970--
KELLER: '70.
KELLER: --a PhD in physics.
And my daughter's
grandfather has a master's
in chemistry in 1948.
KAISER: How about that?
And you, ma'am?
[? SHEREN: ?] Elizabeth
[? Sheren. ?] My father-in-law
is class of 1930, Sloan School,
and I come back for my 30th
reunion, also from
the Sloan School.
And my son is graduating
today in Course 8.
KAISER: All right,
folks, that's it.
If I counted correctly,
there's something
like 12 generations of
MIT graduates represented
in this line.
That's really amazing.
Thank you so much,
and especially to you.
You are wonderful.
[? LAPIN: ?] I want to know
what happened to the tar hut.
I remember coming on
a fancy day in May,
and young men were trying
to climb this hut that
was covered with black tar.
KAISER: Oh, I know
what happened.
Do you know what happened?
Warren will tell
you what happened.
SEAMANS: [INAUDIBLE] rush,
is what that was, yeah.
[? LAPIN: ?] It was funny.
KAISER: Didn't somebody
get hurt or something?
SEAMANS: No, tar
is carcinogenic.
KAISER: Oh, tar is carcinogenic.
It was bad for your health.
[? LAPIN: ?] The paddles
came out the top of the roof.
The paddles came out
the top of the roof.
KAISER: Thank you, old folks.
SEAMANS: Okay, I think we're--
KAISER: MIT's motto, as Warren
told you, is "Mons et Manus"--
"Mens et Manus," which
stands for "Mind and Hand."
At MIT, students learn
by doing, as illustrated
in these next three easy pieces.
Look at the "hugeatron."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- 3, 2, 1, go!
[CHEERING]
- Yeah!
- More and more, our students
are looking for their MIT
experience to be the foundation
of a career and life that
has many dimensions to it.
And I think we're seeing
more of those students,
and I think we're
serving them much better,
as we quite consciously
try to expand
the range of activities
that go beyond the classroom
and laboratory.
- In the end, when
you see your project
helping people rather than
just going up and getting dusty
on a shelf somewhere, it really
inspires you and shows you
what you're really
doing with your life
or why you really want to learn
the engineering that you're
learning.
- It's a great market.
It's waiting to change, and
we believe we can change it.
Thank you.
- One of the things
that the Institute does
is it fosters, like, individual
initiative and creates
opportunities for
that to happen.
- Good evening, everyone.
Welcome to our last Senate
meeting of the term.
- Through the MIT
Washington program,
I spent the summer on the Senate
floor working on legislation.
And I brought that
experience back here to MIT
to be the MIT
[INAUDIBLE] speaker.
- Extracurricular
activities are really
important in that they're
the way that students
get to apply all the theory that
they learn in the classroom.
- [INAUDIBLE] steps on the
[INAUDIBLE],, leans forward,
and lowers himself
to the garden.
- We're not simply educating
the mind of the student,
but we're trying to
educate the student
to be able to actually
accomplish things.
- --and stand himself back up.
- For the first time
since I came to MIT,
I really feel like I have a
purpose beyond my four or five
years here or beyond
the next problem set.
- They learn incredible amounts
about leadership, teamwork,
sportsmanship, and
courage, the willingness
to take risks, and push
their abilities beyond what
they think they can achieve.
- Just being able
to deal with lots
of different types
of situations.
There's one type of
competence that you have
and being able to
sit at a lab bench
and solve a scientific problem.
It's a different skill
set to be able to interact
with different kinds of people
to accomplish some task.
- Participating in these
extracurricular activities
has given me the
confidence to lead
an organization
and the experience
in working with other
people that I really
believe that I can walk
into any kind of a situation
and have had some kind of
experience that has prepared me
for anything that might arise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Robosnail is being developed
in the Hatsopoulos Microfluids
Lab here at MIT.
We're interested
in the fluids lab
at studying fluids
at very small scales.
Microfluidics is becoming
increasingly important today,
mostly because of medical
and biological applications.
People are learning
to build these labs
on a chip, in which you have
fluids that flow through very
small channels, maybe
chemical reactions
take place in those channels.
And the first thing
you need to know,
if you're really going to
design these chips effectively,
is you have to understand
the fluid motion
at those small scales.
A real snail moves by a series
of stretching and compression
waves.
Basically, the
only way the snail
interacts with the substrate is
through a thin layer of fluid.
The slime is actually
incredibly interesting.
It's not a Newtonian
fluid, which
means that the
characteristics of the fluid
change depending on
how you stress it.
And when you go to
very, very small scales,
suddenly you have a
completely different set
of forces that become important.
And you have to learn to
either beat those forces
or use them to your advantage.
Robosnail is answering
the question of,
how can we use these high
pressures in thin films
to actually get something
to propel itself?
- From back here?
- Okay.
- But the--
- The current version of
Robosnail is a prototype.
We built him mostly
as a proof of concept
to show that you really
can generate forward
momentum using the
pressures that build up
in these lubricating layers.
- Upside down?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- I haven't really gone
through it with Brian yet
to know what he--
- Robosnail was really
initiated and designed
by a graduate
student, Brian Chan.
Brian is one of the
most creative students
I've ever come across.
The guy can build
anything mechanical.
You give him-- you tell
him, I need something that
walks on water, he'll build it.
- Last year I had to take--
I was taking a
fluids course, and we
had to do a course project.
And I saw some web pages on
water snails and how they move,
and I decided to
make a robosnail.
I just went to California
and took a look
at the banana slugs, which
are these huge slugs.
They grow to like 7 or 8 inches.
And since they're so big, you
could see what's going on.
And if you look closely at the
bottom, you could see that--
you could see that they
also have these compression
waves, which is actually how I
got the idea for this machine.
- We are extremely good
at designing things
that move on flat surfaces.
If we build a
road, we can design
a vehicle that goes on it.
But snails can climb
up a vertical wall,
and that's something
that we have not
been able to design yet.
And that's something
where, I think,
we can learn a lot from looking
at these natural systems.
- I noticed that a
lot of times people,
they think of bugs or snails,
and they just get grossed out,
and they don't really care.
But if we take the time
to actually observe
these creatures,
we can learn a lot.
- It's taking a
biological creature
that, after all this
time, still exists,
and so his motion must
have some advantage to him,
or it would have fallen out
of the evolutionary chain.
And we're looking at
it, saying, okay, well,
if it has applications
in real life,
then maybe there's
a way to model
it to have applications
in something else
that we want to do later on.
[END PLAYBACK]
KAISER: All right.
I just looked at my watch, and
my watch says that it is 9:23.
The guests of honor are
beginning to process,
and they will be here
in about seven minutes.
You could take a look
up on the screen,
and you'll see them
getting ready to come here
to Killian Court.
This is a good time for me to
outline some of the protocols
when they come.
First of all, we
know that each of you
is going to be very anxious
to get the best possible view
or photograph of your graduate.
But I urge you to be
considerate of the fellow guests
around you.
Please do not stand on the
chairs to take pictures.
We've had people
in the past do that
and they've actually
hurt themselves,
and we don't really want
that to happen to you.
So whatever you do,
don't step on the chairs.
And also, remember when
you're taking pictures
to be mindful of the
people around you
so that you don't block
their view as well.
So you might take a moment
now to introduce yourself
to those people around
you if you don't know them
so that you can work this
out among yourselves.
We would also like to
request that you now
take the time to put your cell
phones in a non-audible mode.
In the unlikely-- and we
hope it doesn't occur--
in the unlikely event that
you'll need medical attention,
the medical tent is located
at the rear of Killian Court.
The words to the national
anthem and the MIT school song
are printed in the commencement
program, in addition to
some helpful information
regarding logistics.
So you might want to
take a look at that.
There will be some
people who will
be wearing red jackets
in the procession, a very
interesting group of people.
And Warren Seamans will
tell you about them.
SEAMANS: The red
jackets, which you
will see I am wearing one
of those red jackets--
I'll tell you why
I am in a minute--
but these mark
the 50-year class.
You can only wear
the red jacket,
the cardinal red jacket, when
you reach the 50-year class.
And so as part of the
procession coming in today,
there will be members
of the class of '50--
KAISER: 4.
SEAMANS: --'54,
coming in as a group,
and they will be
seated as a group.
You can become an
honorary member of a class
and thereby wear a red jacket.
I very proudly wear my
class of 1935 jacket
because I'm an honorary
member of that class.
KAISER: [INAUDIBLE]
SEAMANS: The class
coming in today
includes [? Alec ?] Dreyfus
and our former president
and chairman of the
Corporation, Paul Gray.
KAISER: Thank you
very much, Warren.
I'm going to say
goodbye to you all.
For Warren and myself, it's
been great visiting with you.
And now we're going to
introduce one last tape
and then say good-bye
for Commencement 2004.
MIT has been visited by
many interesting folks
over these past years.
Here is a sampling
and a compilation
we call "Voices at MIT."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- MIT is admired
around the world
as a crucible of creative
thought, a force for progress,
a place where dreams of
generations become reality.
MIT has done much to make
this the American century.
- The Boston area boasts of
several excellent institutions
of higher learning, but
there is only one MIT.
- MIT has shown a
standard of excellence
in education and research
that sets a benchmark
for universities everywhere.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Right now, China is very
short of talented managers.
What we would like
to see more than
anything else is
to see MIT helping
us to train these high-level
managerial persons.
- I promise I will pay
what you are paid here.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
- I personally,
and Microsoft, have
been an incredible beneficiary
of the kind of work
that goes on here and in
other places like this.
Here at MIT, over
50 years ago there
was a vision laid
down by Vannevar Bush
that we're probably about, oh,
20% of the way to achieving.
- I can't tell you how much
I have personally benefited
from this institution.
As part of this
wonderful campaign,
I would like to put $100
million on the table.
[APPLAUSE]
- If one is unfortunate
enough to be disabled,
this is the age
in which to be so.
The disabled have a lot
to thank technology for.
I probably wouldn't
have survived,
and I certainly
wouldn't have been
able to write a
best-selling book
if I had been born any earlier.
- Managing innovation
and figuring out
how to actually turn
good ideas into products
is a really interesting
thing that you probably don't
learn about in universities.
It's not about just technology.
It's about the way
people are treated.
It's about how you
motivate people.
- What was that inspiration
which led suddenly to the world
wide web?
For me, I wanted the thing to be
a project management tool that
allows all to work together, not
management from the top down,
but management in there
working together way.
So I then said, it
should be intercreative,
universal space for
people to communicate
through sharing knowledge.
- We are at the dawn of
a true innovation age.
It's estimated that the entire
store of human knowledge
now doubles every five years.
- I would like to thank MIT for
this incredible honor, which
is, I have to say, the first
academic honor I've ever
received.
So it's nice to
start at the top.
This is such a great
institution dedicated
to the search for the new and
to the openness of thought
that that search requires.
- This case is the
great test of where
we stand on the issue of
freedom and solidarity
and the future of
our own culture.
- For in the end, I believe
the real challenge of history
is to resist the
tendency so prevalent
today to label, to
stereotype, to expose,
to denigrate, and instead
to bring common sense
and empathy to our subjects
so that the past can truly
come alive, if only
for a few moments,
in all of its beauty, glory,
sadness, and complexity.
- Young people
like you are always
the vanguard of any
social movement,
setting an energetic tone
of courage and commitment.
And now we need
you to, once again,
lead us to a higher
and more noble destiny.
- 21st-century America
belongs to you.
Take good care of it.
Thank you and God bless you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
KAISER: Hello again, everyone.
I'm now talking to
Larry Isaacson who
is the director of Mass Brass.
The Mass Brass is
the ensemble who
will be providing the music for
the commencement this morning.
And Larry is currently assistant
director of the music division
at the Boston Conservatory.
He was actually on the faculty
of MIT, on the staff of MIT,
from 19--
what, 1990?
ISAACSON: 1990 to 2000.
KAISER: And now you're at
the Boston Conservatory.
And what are your duties there?
ISAACSON: Well, actually,
I produce their concerts.
There are about
30 concerts a year
that we do, both orchestra,
wind ensemble, musical theater,
dance, opera, and I
oversee all of those.
KAISER: I wonder if you could
tell the folks a little bit
about the music
that they're going
to be hearing as the
graduates process
into Killian Court, Larry.
ISAACSON: Sure.
We put together a really
good combination of music,
things that you
would be familiar,
things like Copland and
Anderson and Gershwin,
and also music that's been
written either for the MIT
Brass Ensemble or for this
graduation in particular.
We had Kevin [? Kaska ?] write
a piece a few years ago for us,
and we actually will
do that as well as
part of the processional for
the students, in addition
to Pomp and Circumstance.
So it's a lot of familiar,
a lot of older things,
and a lot of new things that
we sort of introduce as well.
Should be very enjoyable.
KAISER: I understand that
there's something of your own
in this program as well.
ISAACSON: Yes, the fanfare
when the color guard comes in.
It's actually John Williams.
I didn't write it.
I arranged it for this grouping.
It's his Olympic Fanfare,
one of his Olympic Fanfares,
and we'll use that for
the color guard today.
KAISER: I'll be looking
forward to hearing
that, because, as you know, I
play a brass instrument myself,
and I don't think there's a
lovelier sound than brass.
Tell me, what are
you going to do next?
ISAACSON: Well, I'm
going to head off
to Aspen in about a week and
do their July 4th concert.
It's only-- I gather there's
10,000 people here today-- it's
only 5,000 in that audience.
It's a small audience.
KAISER: A comedown,
but not much of one.
Larry, it's always a pleasure
to hear you and the Mass Brass
and to hear your
wonderful music.
What would commencement
be without it?
Thank you very much.
ISAACSON: Thank you, Jay.
KAISER: And the
stage is now yours.
[MUSIC - MASS BRASS]
ANNOUNCER: Ladies and gentlemen,
the academic procession
will enter Killian Court
in about 10 minutes.
At this time, please welcome the
MIT Campus Police Color Guard.
[MUSIC - JOHN WILLIAMS, "OLYMPIC
FANFARE"]
[MUSIC - MASS BRASS]
Ladies and gentlemen,
the academic procession,
led by the Chief Marshal,
will now enter Killian Court.
[MUSIC - MASS BRASS]
SEAMANS: Welcome to the--
can you hear me, Larry?
OK, OK.
Welcome to our 136th
MIT Commencement.
The first one in 1868
had 13 graduates.
We have a few more
than that today.
[MUSIC - MASS BRASS]
The president of the
MIT Alumni Association
carries the mace, which
is the symbolic instrument
for the Institute.
There's Chuck Vest,
current president.
KAISER: There's Rafael Bras
who's the chair of the faculty.
And this is what-- did you
mention it's the 138th?
SEAMANS: 136th.
KAISER: 136th.
SEAMANS: It's hard to tell
because in 1944, there
were two graduations
during World War II.
KAISER: Ah, right.
SEAMANS: So it's
either 136 or 137.
KAISER: President Vest is
wearing the recently minted MIT
gown, the crimson and gray.
This year, there are going
to be 2,205 undergraduates
and graduate students scheduled
to receive 1,114 bachelor's
degrees, 1,161 master's, 211
doctorates, and 10 engineering
degrees.
SEAMANS: This is the procession
of the faculty coming in
to be seated on the stage.
The stage is covered by a huge
sail made by the MIT ocean
engineering faculty.
KAISER: There's a glimpse
of all of the degrees
that are going to be handed out.
And you can see what a logistic
problem it is to get them
all stacked up in
the right order
so that when their
student comes up
onto the platform as her
name is pronounced, that you
gets the right diploma.
SEAMANS: That close-up
of the mace you saw
has the beaver, MIT's mascot,
on its top, and the bottom of it
is an acorn.
KAISER: You're looking
at Steve Lerman there.
He is the master
of the new graduate
dorm on Albany Street, very
active member of the MIT
community.
SEAMANS: And there's a
partial view of the audience
for the commencement ceremony.
Most of those people started
gathering here about 7:30
this morning.
So they've been out there
for, most of them, for two
to two and a half hours already.
KAISER: The sail
works as, of course,
a protection from the sun
when you're sitting there.
But it's also, in
the past it's acted
as an umbrella when
there have been
really inclement commencements.
SEAMANS: We should
point out that this
is sort of a miracle day.
The last two weeks have
been almost continuous rain
here in the Boston area, and
yesterday it rained off and on
most of the day.
Yet today came forth just this
beautiful, cool, wonderful day.
Rain is predicted
again for tomorrow.
So it's this sun is shine
brightly on MIT today.
KAISER: Yes.
I mean, if the weather were
traffic, MIT would be--
let's say if the weather
were New York traffic,
MIT would be a New Yorker
trying to get across the street.
We've managed to dodge
so many different storm
systems yesterday and today.
We had yesterday the
Hooding Ceremony,
and it rained before it.
Then when the ceremony
started, the sun shone.
And when the ceremony was over,
the clouds came back in again,
and it rained some more.
And just look at the
sky above the dome now.
There isn't a cloud in the sky.
I can't remember in recent
years a commencement which has
had a cloudless sky like this.
SEAMANS: For those of you who
may be watching who are not
familiar with MIT, this is MIT's
Great Court, Killian Court,
which was dedicated
in 1916, 88 years ago.
And it has traditionally
served as MIT's open living
room, where everything from
graduations, commencements,
to inauguration
of new presidents,
to scientific happenings,
to celebrations
of the end of World War II,
just whatever has been happening
is sort of reflected by
the events in the Great
Court, Killian Court.
KAISER: Yes.
Now, there is the president
of MIT, Chuck Vest.
As I said, this is going to be
probably his last commencement
as president.
Of course, everything depends
on who the new president is
and when the new
president can come.
But Chuck announced
several months ago
that he was stepping down.
Right now, he's talking
to Elias Zerhouni,
who is director of the
National Institutes of Health.
And Dr. Zerhouni will provide
the principal address.
SEAMANS: Now you see
entering the 50-year class
with their red jackets.
This is a symbol
of MIT's longevity.
But since 1966,
the 50-year class
has been allowed to wear
the cardinal red jacket.
So these are all members
of the class of '50--
'54 coming in.
KAISER: In that
previous shot, kind
of a poignant
picture there, that
was of Paul Gray,
who is now taking
his seat with the other
50-year [? corps. ?]
Paul has, of course,
spent, I think,
41 years attending commencements
at MIT sitting on this stage.
And now this will
be the first one
that he'll spend sitting
with his comrades.
SEAMANS: There's
[? Phil ?] Curry,
who is the dean of the School of
Humanities and Social Studies.
KAISER: Social Sciences.
SEAMANS: Social Sciences.
KAISER: And there
is Tom Magnanti,
who's dean of the
School of Engineering,
with the orange tie.
And who's that?
That's the dean of
the Sloan School.
I believe that's Dick
Schmalensee, Dick Schmalensee.
So there are three deans,
three of the five deans,
and the chair of the
faculty in the lower left.
There's Eleanor Westney,
the woman in the orange cap.
She is also Sloan School.
Her specialty is Japan.
And--
ANNOUNCER: Ladies and gentlemen,
KAISER: --she's
going to go back to--
ANNOUNCER: --the guests--
KAISER: --Japan next year--
ANNOUNCER: --of honor--
KAISER: --for her sabbatical.
ANNOUNCER: --the Class of 2004.
SEAMANS: We're just about
to have the procession
of the Class of 2004.
They come in from Memorial
Drive on to the stage.
[MUSIC - MASS BRASS]
KAISER: Now, I know
on the right there
is Larry Benedict, who
is the dean for Student
Affairs at MIT.
And although he's
shaded, I can't tell yet,
that should be--
to Larry's right that
should be Bob Redwine.
But it doesn't look
like Bob, who is--
Bob Redwine is the dean of
Undergraduate Education.
It's getting closer.
Those are the two deans,
the two most important deans
in the undergraduate
life of these students--
Bob Redwine on the screen
left and Larry Benedict,
screen right.
A terrific duo.
They've been in their offices
now, I guess, for three years,
and they've just done an
absolutely splendid job.
MIT is incredibly lucky
to have two gifted--
SEAMANS: The group
standing on either side,
but you can see to the
right now, are the families.
This morning we found
that there were people
from as far away as Perth,
Australia and Argentina,
India, of course.
People from around
the world have
come for this glorious event.
KAISER: Other
speakers at the event
today, beside President
Vest and Elias Zerhouni,
will include the president of
the Graduate Student Council,
Erich Caulfield,
and Maria Hidalgo,
who's president of
the Class of 2004, who
will present the class gift.
The Invocation will be delivered
by another MIT long-timer,
Reverend Robert M. Randolph,
who is Senior Associate
Dean for Students at MIT and an
affiliate minister at Harvard
University's Memorial Church.
SEAMANS: We should
indicate, perhaps,
that the commentary
as we are doing it,
in case you've joined recently,
is being given by Jay Kaiser
and by Warren Seamans, myself.
KAISER: Yes, I'm Jay Kaiser.
And to my right is--
SEAMANS: Warren Seamans.
KAISER: Warren was--
Warren was director of the MIT
Museum for many, many years
before he retired in 1996.
Warren retired two years
before I did, and both of us
can attest to the
glories of retirement.
[MUSIC - MASS BRASS, "POMP AND
CIRCUMSTANCE"]
And there's the
mace, the MIT mace,
standing up above
the crowd there.
[MUSIC - MASS BRASS, "POMP AND
CIRCUMSTANCE"]
Dr. Zerhouni is the 15th
director of the NIH.
He took office in May of 2002,
and his major focus at the NIH
has been in laying out
new pathways of discovery
in clinical research
enterprise and research teams
for re-engineering clinical
work, primarily concerned
with biomedical research.
SEAMANS: As the graduates
file into the Killian Court,
they must get into
a certain order,
because as their names are
called they go under the awning
and receive their diploma.
At the time they do this,
they are read simultaneously.
The grad students and
the undergrads are read.
So they are divided.
So they go up, and you'll see
two diplomas being given out
almost simultaneously.
Earlier you saw the stacks of
diplomas, which must be exactly
in order so that each person
gets exactly the diploma he's
entitled to.
There we see the
stacks of diplomas.
[MUSIC - MASS BRASS, "POMP AND
CIRCUMSTANCE"]
KAISER: There's the MIT mace
carried into the procession
by the--
SEAMANS: President of the
MIT Alumni Association.
KAISER: President of the
That mace goes back
how far, Warren?
The beaver's on top
of the mace, right?
SEAMANS: Yes, the
beaver's on top,
and an acorn is on the bottom.
KAISER: Uh-huh.
And what's in the middle there?
It's an urn, right?
SEAMANS: Yes.
KAISER: And there are
ashes in that urn, right?
SEAMANS: I do not really
know what's in there.
This particular urn only--
particular mace is only,
perhaps, 20 to 22 years old.
So a relatively new tradition
in the entire proceedings.
KAISER: I see, carrying
the mace is a new--
SEAMANS: Carrying the mace.
KAISER: Well, we know what the--
we did a hooding ceremony
yesterday, as I said,
211 doctorates were
hooded yesterday.
I might say a word
about what that means.
When you become a
PhD, you get a hood.
And you could see the
backs here of the faculty,
all of those colorful
things there,
the yellows and the blues.
Those are hoods.
Those hoods go back
to medieval times
when they reflect a time when
scholars were mendicants.
And they would lecture,
and for their pains,
they would be given money or
food or things of that sort,
which were kept in these hoods.
Now they're strictly
ornamental, and what they do
is they reflect the school
that the graduate came from.
For example, my
PhD was from Yale,
and it's a very deep blue.
The MIT hood will be
crimson and gray--
SEAMANS: Cardinal.
KAISER: Cardinal, of
course, cardinal and gray.
And yesterday, we gave the
hoods to the PhD candidates,
which means that this ceremony
can be cut by about an hour.
It took that long to--
we used to give the hoods
in the same ceremony.
But dividing these
ceremonies in two
was a wonderful idea
because not only
did it give special
recognition to PhDs,
but it also enabled
this ceremony
to move along at a faster clip.
SEAMANS: The books that
everybody is holding
is the commencement
program, which
also lists all of the graduates
in the order by the school,
and usually it lists
the hometown as well.
Kathryn Willmore, vice
president and secretary
of the Corporation,
Allan Bufferd, treasurer.
[MUSIC - MASS BRASS]
KAISER: So we've got what?
What did I say, 2,000?
SEAMANS: We have 2,200 or--
KAISER: 2,200.
People are marching in from
Howard Johnson Athletic Center,
across Mass Avenue, and
up into Killian Court.
SEAMANS: Chuck Vest,
outgoing president.
KAISER: Dr. Zerhouni
next to him.
SEAMANS: Killian Court
was dedicated 30 years ago
this year in honor of James
Rhyne Killian, former president
and chairman of the Corporation
at the time of his retirement
from the latter.
Prior to that time, it had
been known as the Great Court.
And it always, as I
indicated earlier,
had always been the
center of MIT activity.
However, graduations
traditionally
were not held in
the Great Court.
Starting in early
1920s, they decided
to try to hold the graduation
ceremonies in the court.
But in '23, the tent fell
down that they were under,
and they moved back to
Symphony Hall for most
of the next 20 to 25 years.
Then after the Rockwell
Cage was built post-war,
they moved graduation
to that facility,
where it remained until about
20 years we moved back outside.
And weather has
usually cooperated,
although there have been times
when raincoats were furnished
to everybody attending,
and umbrellas were usually,
in those two or
three years, were
the primary thing
you saw looking out
from this direction.
For those of you familiar
with this view of the court,
you turn around and
see the view going back
toward the Boston skyline.
There's now a large
tent across there,
which blocks off the view of
the river and Memorial Drive
and pretty well hides the view,
which is always spectacular.
KAISER: Those flowers that you
see there are not always there.
They are brought in especially
for the commencement exercises.
And what will happen after
the commencement exercises
is that they'll all be
taken in to the lobby
beneath the dome,
which you now see,
and they're sold to
the general public,
and the proceeds go
to some charitable--
SEAMANS: Community
Service Fund, I believe.
KAISER: The Community
Service Fund.
So that's always a great
event to go down and buy some
of those beautiful flowers.
They don't go to waste,
go to a very good cause.
SEAMANS: The dome
you currently see
has been the scene of some
of MIT's most famous hacks--
the police cruiser on
the dome, the helicopter
earlier this year.
It's always been a
student-central thing to have
been--
to have done a hack
on the main dome.
KAISER: Yes, the students
know how to get up there.
They're very clever
about getting up there.
SEAMANS: Even though
it's illegal, of course.
KAISER: The most
recent hack there
was a beautiful, beautiful
reproduction of the Kitty Hawk.
SEAMANS: The Wright
brothers' plane.
KAISER: The Wright
And the hawks, the
red-tailed hawks
that have taken up residence
at MIT, one of them
is named Kitty Hawk.
SEAMANS: [LAUGHS]
KAISER: And I think that
he was named Kitty Hawk not
after the Wright Brothers
plane, but after the MIT hack.
The hack is-- it does
cause some consternation
on the part of officialdom at
MIT because on the one hand,
it is a remarkable expression
of student ingenuity.
On the other hand,
it's dangerous to go up
on to the dome.
But these are MIT
students, and if you
block all of the known
entrances to the dome,
they'll find another way.
SEAMANS: They'll
find another one.
KAISER: And even
if it means scaling
the columns from outside.
There is Dr. Vest now, and
a good shot of Dr. Vest
and Dr. Zerhouni, who
came to the United States
from Algeria in 1975.
He earned a medical degree
from the University of Algiers.
And he was accepted as
a radiology resident
at John Hopkins University
School of Medicine,
where he became chairman of
the Department of Radiology
and Radiological Science,
radiologist-in-chief,
and president of the
Clinical Practice
Association, executive
vice dean, and professor
of biomedical engineering.
He singly or jointly
holds eight patents
for various
computerized tomography
and magnetic resonance
imaging inventions.
And it's significant that
our speaker today would come
from the biological sciences.
That is one of the
burgeoning areas
in most institutions
of higher learning
and particularly in MIT.
It will be interesting to see
what Dr. Zerhouni has to say.
In the upper left-hand
corner there, you
saw Bob Silbey, who's dean
of the School of Science.
SEAMANS: Those who have
received a commission to ROTC
will be wearing their uniform
for the respective service
that they did their
ROTC training in.
KAISER: What I've
been looking for,
as the graduates have processed
down the center aisle,
is I've been looking for some
originality in their costume.
And I don't see any.
SEAMANS: No, it's
been very staid.
And only one or two
cell phones as well.
KAISER: I mean, I don't
see a single adorned--
SEAMANS: Not one.
KAISER: --mortarboard.
Amazing.
SEAMANS: A few minutes
ago-- a few seconds ago,
we saw the class
of '04's banner.
Each class has a banner
that's prepared for them
by the Institute, and
then this is brought out
for reunions and other
events that the class has.
It's something maintained
by the Institute.
KAISER: There's
[INAUDIBLE] cell phone.
SEAMANS: This too goes--
that tradition goes back
to 1868, the class banner.
KAISER: Yeah.
Yes, I've noticed that over
the last-- for several years
the classes has been
less adventurous.
SEAMANS: Yeah, there's
another cell phone.
There's two cell phones.
Last year, almost
everybody who came in
had a cell phone as they
were talking to somebody.
KAISER: Yeah, and they
were usually talking
to the person next to them.
SEAMANS: Maybe that is
something that has become passe.
Let's hope so.
But I think it's
fascinating that there's
so little adornment.
KAISER: Yeah, yeah.
I believe that we're going
into a conservative cycle.
Oh, boy.
That's Bob Brown on the right.
He is provost of MIT.
SEAMANS: Provost is the
chief academic officer
of an institute.
KAISER: And the word "provost"--
and I don't know if you knew
this, Warren-- but
the word "provost"
actually comes from the
same root as the word
for "preposition."
SEAMANS: Really?
KAISER: That's right.
It's the same word.
It's the Latin [LATIN],, and
it's from the past participle.
And a provost is someone
that you should never
end an argument with.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAMANS: As I say, he is
the chief academic officer,
and everybody else reports
through him to the president.
KAISER: We've been talking
about Dr. Zerhouni giving
the principal address.
The president of
MIT, of course, also
delivers an address each year.
And when the president
delivers the address,
it's called the charge.
And so what the president
actually does is,
I think the proper
usage is the president
charges the class,
which seems to be
a bit unfortunate since
he's been charging
the class for the
last four years.
SEAMANS: We won't
say in which way.
Behind--
KAISER: Yes?
SEAMANS: Behind
him-- behind the flag
is Ike Colbert, who's
dean of the Grad School.
KAISER: Yeah, dean of
the Graduate School.
There's a great shot
of the adornment.
I wish I knew the
names of those flowers.
I don't, so I'll
just point them out.
There's some blue ones,
and there's some pink ones.
SEAMANS: Ageratum and--
KAISER: Geraniums.
Are those--
SEAMANS: Yeah, the
orange ones are--
KAISER: Are those blue ones--
SEAMANS: The pinkish
ones are geranium.
KAISER: Are the blue
ones hydrangeas?
SEAMANS: No, they're ageratum.
KAISER: What?
SEAMANS: Ageratum.
KAISER: Ageratum.
This is a family show, Warren.
So ageratum, ageratum yourself.
SEAMANS: I could
call it ageratum.
KAISER: What?
SEAMANS: Could call it
ageratum, I suppose.
KAISER: How do you know that?
SEAMANS: I was a horticulture
major in college.
KAISER: Well, will
wonders never cease?
A horticulture major, really?
SEAMANS: Yeah, I
switched early on--
KAISER: I'll be darned.
SEAMANS: --to something else.
Well, I mean, here's
some department heads.
There's--
SEAMANS: Stan Anderson.
KAISER: Stan Anderson,
architecture.
SEAMANS: Head of architecture.
KAISER: And Ian Hutchinson.
What is-- I'm not sure
of his department.
That's Ian Hutchinson
in the blue.
And I don't recognize the man
with the yellow next to him.
That's Steve Lippard
in the MIT gown there.
Well, it's not an
MIT gown, is it?
Looks a little like it.
And Steve Lippard is
head of chemistry,
and he's talking to Lester
Thurow, the man who used
to be dean of the School of--
SEAMANS: Management.
KAISER: The--
SEAMANS: Sloan School.
KAISER: The Sloan School.
And next to him, I
don't know who he is,
but he looks
awfully comfortable.
He's got his feet up
on the railing there.
SEAMANS: The dark glasses.
KAISER: All right.
Yes, John Belcher is talking--
that's John Belcher with
the tassel over his left eye--
and he's talking to Steve
Lerman, who is on his right
and directly in front of him.
Now, the next person
we're going to see
is the mayor of the
city of Cambridge.
And he's the one
nearest us, and he's
talking to Phil Clay,
who is the chancellor.
He was from the Department
of Urban Studies.
And the mayor, of course,
presided last a few weeks ago
over that historic evening
when same-sex marriages
were allowed in Cambridge.
And Phil Clay is sandwiched
in between the mayor
on the left and Mr. Mead,
who is the new chairman
of the Corporation.
He's now adjusting his cuff.
That's him.
And right above him-- that's it.
SEAMANS: We're reaching
just about the end
of the procession, I believe.
Takes about a half an hour
for all the 2,200 people
to get into the
great Killian Court.
[MUSIC - MASS BRASS]
KAISER: All right.
Now you can see
the PhD candidates.
They already have their hoods.
There was one PhD
candidate yesterday
who actually came
up on the platform,
and she already had a hood.
This was her second PhD.
And you might catch
a glimpse of her.
I don't if she's allowed
to wear two hoods,
but it'd be interesting
to see if you do that.
Well, I mean, not allowed.
I'm sure you could allow.
There isn't any hood
policemen around.
But I wonder what the protocol
is if you have two PhDs.
And she's now enrolled in
a program to get a third
doctorate, the
MIT-Harvard Health--
joint medical health program.
The music in the background,
as I'm sure you can hear,
is Mass Brass, directed by
Larry Isaacson, the brass
ensemble that entertains
the commencement every year.
Larry was actually a member
of MIT teaching staff
from 1990 to 2000.
He is now assistant director
of the music division
of the Boston Conservatory.
And right after
today's event, well,
just within a
couple of days, he's
going to be hopping a
plane to Aspen, Colorado,
where he will lead the
Aspen Festival Concert.
SEAMANS: This is a view from
behind the speakers podium,
where very soon the Commencement
ceremonies will start.
[MUSIC - MASS BRASS]
There are Priscilla
Gray and Becky Vest,
the current and immediate
past presidents' wives.
OK.
We are ready to sign off because
the Commencement is coming.
It's commencing.
KAISER: This is Warren
Seamans and Jay Kaiser saying
goodbye for another year.
PRESENTER: The Corporation
and the faculty
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
are now declared
convened together
with this assembly on the
occasion of the Commencement
Exercises of this Institution
for the conferring of degrees.
The stage assembly
and the audience
will please rise
for the Invocation
by Dean Robert
Randolph and remain
standing to join
the MIT Chorallaries
in the singing of one verse
of "The Star-Spangled Banner."
RANDOLPH: Almighty God,
known by many names,
heard in many voices, we invoke
your presence with us this day.
Today we celebrate
the accomplishments
of those who receive diplomas
and of those who begin
new chapters in their lives.
We invoke your
blessings upon them.
There are those here who
have passed through MIT
and seldom looked
to right or left.
There are those here who have
struggled and arrive here today
battered and bruised.
Make each mindful, we pray, of
what they have accomplished.
Let success mend self-esteem
and give perspective
to achievement.
Bless as well,
Almighty God, those
who have supported them in
their work, in the classroom,
at home, and on the way--
teachers who have
given of themselves
in ways that will
only be understood
with the passage of time,
families who have sacrificed
much, friends who have learned
from them and taught them,
as only peers can.
We ask special blessings
on President Charles Vest
and his good wife Rebecca.
They have given much
to this Institution,
and we ask that the next
chapter in their lives
be as successful as
their time with us.
We pray for the
security of our nation
and for the safety of
those who defend freedom,
whoever and wherever they are.
Make us ever mindful of those
on whose shoulders we stand,
as well as those who
follow in our path.
And as we celebrate
accomplishment and transition,
may we continue to seek wisdom.
Hear our prayer.
Amen.
[MUSIC - MASS BRASS, "THE STAR
SPANGLED BANNER"]
(SINGING) O, say can you see
by the dawn's early light
what so proudly we hailed at
the twilight's last gleaming?
Whose broad stripes
and bright stars
through the perilous fight
o'er the ramparts we watched
were so gallantly streaming?
And the rocket's red glare,
the bombs bursting in air
gave proof through the night
that our flag was still there.
O, say does that star-spangled
banner yet wave o'er
the land of the free and
the home of the brave?
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER: Please be seated.
I'm pleased to welcome
to the platform
the honorable
Michael A. Sullivan,
mayor of the city of Cambridge.
Mayor?
[APPLAUSE]
I'm also pleased to welcome
Dr. Elias A. Zerhouni, director
of the National
Institutes of Health,
who will now give the
graduation address.
Dr. Zerhouni.
[APPLAUSE]
ZERHOUNI: Thank you very much.
It's really a privilege for
me to be here and celebrate
with you on this beautiful day.
I also wish my
mother-in-law was here
to see what I was doing
today, because I still
have to convince
her on a daily basis
that her daughter made the
right choice many years ago.
I'm honored to be here because
I also, as a parent myself,
can feel the joy of your parents
and friends who are here.
As a parent, I remember
the birth of my first son
as if it was yesterday.
And I can tell you,
your parents also
remember those 22 years ago
and days when you were born.
For you, those 22 years may have
seemed very long and arduous.
But I can tell you, for
parents they are very short.
They all remember you
as a baby, and they
can't believe how you've become
such a formidable graduate
of one of the most prestigious
institutions in the world.
And that's an
illustration of what
I call the relativity
principle of time and aging.
The older you are, the
faster time seems to go by
and the faster tuition bills
seem to come through as well.
But you know, you are the legacy
of your parents to this world,
and they all deserve our
heartfelt recognition
for doing such a good job.
And I'd like all the
graduates, if you don't mind,
to give a round of
applause to your parents.
[APPLAUSE]
It's also a great
honor for me to give
this address in the last year
of President Charles Vest's
extraordinary tenure at MIT.
There's no question
that Dr. Vest,
from my point of view as
a federal agency official,
today is one of the
most influential thought
leaders in higher education.
He has this rare
combination that you
don't find a lot in
life that combines
vision and flawless execution.
Well, last night he
conducted the Boston Pops
with a flawless
execution, I hear.
President Vest, we're impressed.
Recently, my younger
son Adam actually
was initiated in a fraternity
called Phi Kappa Psi.
And as I was
checking to make sure
that this was a good
fraternity, a decent one,
I found out that Dr. Vest was
a member of that fraternity.
So when people ask me
now about my son Adam,
I say, oh, don't worry.
He belongs to the exact same
fraternity Dr. Vest belongs to.
So I'm very proud to do
this in his last year.
But when I was preparing
my speech, what can
you say to 2,200
very bright graduates
that will make a
difference in telling them
about where you
see life and where
you see your field of science,
where you see yourself?
And as I was
preparing my speech,
I was looking at, what was
the best strategy to do that?
And I came across the story
of a commencement speaker
at Yale University
who had the great idea
of using every letter
of the Yale name
as a starting concept.
So he used Y for youth, and
he went on and on about youth.
And then he used A for
ability, which you all have,
and he went on and on.
And from the back of
the room somebody said,
thank god we're not
the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
[LAUGHTER]
So I give up on that strategy.
I'm not going to use
that strategy today.
Instead, I'll tell
you about what
I think are the very critical
both scientific challenges
of the 21st century, but
also, what is your role in it?
The challenge, frankly,
for us in the 21st century
is one that we have
brought upon ourselves.
And I'll just go back
in history a little bit
to give you the perspective
of how I see it.
When you think
about the universe,
you hear that about 13.7 billion
years ago there was a big bang,
and off of that big
bang came the universe.
And then planets and
solar systems and galaxies
organized themselves.
That was the first big bang,
but there were other big bangs.
The Earth came about
5 billion years ago.
And about 4 billion years
ago, with a mysterious event,
life appeared.
And what happened is
that through replication
of very special molecules, DNA
and RNA, something very unique
happened, where by
natural evolution
allowed, through multiple
variations and survival
of the fittest, the emergence
of a very diverse life on Earth.
But there is a third big bang.
And this is the
one you're living
in today, which you
have to take account of,
and that is the big
bang of knowledge.
It occurred about
100,000 years ago,
when about 10,000
individuals, at most--
as we look at the
genome and we look
at the variation of the genome
across the human population,
it is very clear
that all of us have
come from the same
founding population
of 10,000 individuals in
Africa about 100,000 years ago.
So we're not that different from
each other in historical terms.
And yet that changed
the game of life,
because through knowledge,
through our ability,
through our intelligence we're
able to transfer information
from one child-- from
one parent to a child,
from a parent to another one.
And through generations,
we're able to develop
tools of adaptation the
world has never seen.
We've been able to change
our environment at a speed,
at a velocity, that is much
faster than what we can adapt
to ourselves through
our natural mechanisms
of natural evolution.
Let me give you an example.
Obesity is an emerging
public health threat.
This year, the Center
for Disease Control
said that obesity
will be the second--
is the second cause of premature
mortality and morbidity
in this country.
Now, why is that?
Because for millions
of years, our genes
evolve in the context
of food scarcity.
There was not a lot
of food around us
for millions of years.
And all of a sudden,
because of our intelligence,
because of our
knowledge, we changed
that in less than 50 years.
Most of our genes
are, in fact, designed
to allow you to accumulate
energy and keep that energy,
which then translates itself
into overweight and obesity.
Well, what are we
going to do about it?
What I will dare
to say to you is
that life sciences
and their applications
will be the defining challenge
of the 21st century, bar none.
And the reason is that we
are changing our environment
at a speed which will
require us to understand
life sciences to a degree
we do not understand today.
And let me tell you, it will
require the intelligence
and commitment of many classes
of graduates like yours.
It is not coming from biology.
The solution will not
come from biology alone.
It will come from the
integration of biology
and computer sciences and
mathematics and physics
and chemistry.
And we want to encourage
that to happen.
Why is this a great
opportunity for you?
Let me tell you a little story.
About a few weeks ago,
I was at a meeting
of the annual convention of all
the biotechnology executives.
All the CEOs of the many
biotechnology companies
in this country were there
assembled in New York
with their investment bankers.
Now, you know this must be
a very important meeting
for someone who is trying
to get funds for their idea.
And I just conducted a
poll, and I said to them,
I am the director of the NIH.
I'm supposed to-- as the
nation's medical research
agency, I want to
ask you a question.
How much do you think
you know of what you
need to know to be effective in
combating obesity or diabetes
and any of the health challenges
that we have in front of us?
And I asked the question,
do you think you know
90% of what you need to know?
And no one answered that.
50%?
No one raised their hand.
20%?
So I say, what
about less than 10%?
Everybody raised their hand.
This is from the leaders
of life sciences today.
So think about it.
Think how much opportunity
there is in front of you.
90% of what there is to
discover is still ahead of us.
Now I turned to the
investment bankers,
and I said, well, I
don't understand this.
Now, you are
investing good dollars
on people who just
admitted in front of you
that they know less than 10%
than what they need to know.
Can you imagine?
And the reason is simple.
It is such a great challenge,
and the risk-reward
is so great.
If you can find just
the cure for one
of the major
diseases of mankind,
you will affect the relationship
between our environment
and ourselves.
So it's important, I think,
to keep that in perspective
and to understand that
there is a real race going
on between our ability to
understand how we respond
to our environment
biologically and our ability
to change that environment in
ways and consequences that we--
with consequences that we
may not always predict.
So as the NIH director,
I have to give you
some advice about how to
conduct yourself, then,
for the next challenge, if
that's the challenge that we
think is there.
And now I can only do
this with no certainty,
obviously, about what
the right answer is.
I can only talk to you
about myself and the rules
I've used in life to
go around and do this.
First and foremost,
I learned one thing
because I came from
another country actually.
I came from Algeria when I
was 24 years old to America.
And I immigrated, and I had
$300 in my pocket, a new wife,
and no friends, and no family.
And basically, this
is where I learned
that you can't make a
contribution unless you're
connected to others and you're
able to connect to others.
So I developed these rules
called my 50-50 rules.
You have to have
a balance in life
because you never know
when you are going to need
the interactions of others.
So what are these 50-50 rules?
Well, the first rule that I'd
like to share with you is this.
Today you're going
to receive a diploma.
What you know today,
I can assure you,
is 50% wrong and 50% right.
The challenge for you now is to
figure out what part is right
and what part is wrong.
Now, don't take my
speech as an excuse
to go and ask for a
reimbursement on your tuition.
I don't think they will do that.
But on the other hand, I think
it's a very important way
to look at the
knowledge fund that you
have as new scientists,
new graduates of MIT.
I think it is important
to also realize
that in life many of
your contributions
will not come from
your core discipline.
They will come from
disciplines that you probably
have no contact with typically.
And this is the other
50-50 rule that I
will like to leave you with.
Read 50% of what you read in the
area that you're interested in,
but make sure that
50% of what you read
is unrelated to
what you have to do.
And I did this
consistently because I
had to learn a new language.
I had to connect with new
friends and new disciplines.
50% of what I read
was in radiology.
I loved medical
imaging because it
combined mathematics and
physics, which I love,
and medicine, which I think
gave me the human contact,
and that's why I worked and
made these contributions.
But 50% of the time I would read
things outside of radiology.
It's really fun to see
the world that way.
But it's also more
fun to understand
that you are smarter when
you're in the company
of smarter people than you.
It is amazing to see the
enrichment that you get
from interacting with others.
So my rule is that
50% of my friends
have to be from walks of life
that are not directly related
to my walk of life.
And more importantly, I try
to make sure that at least 50%
of my friends are
smarter than I am.
Because you can be
assured that at least half
of your life contributions
will be stimulated by others
that are interacting
with you, and you
will stimulate others as well.
Often you hear about the spark
of genius that somebody had,
this unique individual, and we
all admire these individuals.
But it's rarely true
that it happens to people
who are completely isolated.
Throughout scientific
history, you've
always had that
interaction of people,
founder groups that got together
and created new advances.
Witness Watson and Crick.
Watson was a zoologist,
and Crick was a physicist.
And coming together,
they created
the field of molecular biology.
Look at laboratories
around the world that
have been very productive.
They've been productive because
they have, in fact, encouraged
the clustering of people from
diverse backgrounds coming
from diverse horizons
with different ideas.
Now, this process is
admittedly social.
It is not an individual process.
It is a process you
have to participate in.
But now I'm going to tell you
about some of the exceptions
that I've learned as well.
People will tell you that if
you go and talk about things
you do not understand to
people who do not know you,
you will tend to
look a little stupid.
And the objection
that I hear a lot
is, but you can look
foolish asking questions
about fields you
do not understand
and those people
who do not know you.
Well, that's true.
That's very true.
I asked a lot of stupid
questions in my life,
and you will too.
But the one thing
I can tell you is
that it's not deadly to
ask a stupid question.
What's deadly is to not
ask the right question
at the right time.
The other is people
will also tell you
if you talk too much
about your ideas,
someone will steal
them from you.
Well, my response to
that is that if you
have ideas that are
so easy to steal from,
they must not be that good.
In fact, my experience
is different.
With truly original
ideas, the response
is that most people
don't believe you.
One of the three
or four things I
did in my life that were
semi-original were fiercely
disbelieved and criticized
and initially rejected
for both publication, and most
importantly, NIH funding, which
is the agency that
I direct today.
So don't despair.
I even carried this
further, this 50-50 rule
further, because I
spent half of my life
in our country and half of
my life in another country.
I don't recommend you
push that to that extent.
But as any rule that you
make for young colleagues
that you talk to, there
are big exceptions.
First, this rule doesn't mean
that you should develop a split
personality.
It shouldn't split
your integrity.
Your integrity has
to be constant, 100%.
Another one is that
in affairs of love,
I don't think you should
play the 50-50 rule.
That would be deadly,
so don't do it.
And last but not
least, I would say
you should have big dreams,
full dreams, not half dreams.
It's very simple.
You can't put a large
box in a small box.
Well, you cannot put a full
life in a small dream box.
What you need is to have a box,
a dream box, and a life that
is as full as the
potential you have today.
For universities and
teachers, there's
just no greater
satisfaction than seeing
you graduate and enter
your professional calling.
I think you have the
potential to transform
our understanding of the
relationship between humanity
and environment this century.
I think you need to do it.
And you know something?
There's nothing greater than
coming from a university
like MIT to be able to do that.
I actually read that
if you asked yourself
about the 100 governments
that existed in 1900, how
many of the 100 governments
that were active in 1900
are still unchanged today?
You know what the answer is?
Two.
There are only two governments
in the world that stayed stable
for the past 104 years--
the United States
and Great Britain.
If you asked yourself
the question,
what about universities?
Well, let me ask you, if
you took the year 1500
and you took the 100
universities that
were active in 1500, how
many of them do you think
have survived intact in 2004?
The number is 75 out of 100.
So what I can tell you
is that universities
beat governments hands down.
There is no institution that can
survive as long as a university
if it's cared for by its
graduates and alumni.
The only institutions
that last longer
are the institutions
of the church.
So I'm sure that
MIT will certainly
be here at the end of the
century and many more centuries
to come, thanks to you,
as newly minted graduates
and future alumni.
I understand the
Class of 1954 is here,
and I want to salute
them for coming back
to their institution.
This is--
[APPLAUSE]
Because you know?
We're all engaged throughout
the world on the global basis
with a game that has no
frontier, a game that
has no nationality,
and that is to build
the fund of
knowledge of humanity
to the service of humanity.
This was my message.
Believe in yourself.
Life sciences are
a great challenge.
We have a lot to do, and I hope
you'll join us in this fight.
Good luck to you, and
God may bless you all.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER: Thank
you, Dr. Zerhouni,
for your wisdom
and your insights.
And also thank you
for the great service
that you're rendering
to our country
with your leadership of the
National Institutes of Health.
Now Mr. Erich Caulfield,
president of the Graduate
Student Council, will
present a salute to MIT
from the graduate student body.
Following Mr. Caulfield,
Miss Maria Hidalgo,
president of the senior class,
will present the class gift
to President Vest, after which
the president will deliver
his charge to the graduates.
CAULFIELD: Good morning,
family and friends of MIT.
From the dawn of the
human experiment,
we have grappled
with the challenge
and the potential
inherent in our existence.
Today, my graduate student
brethren and my sistren,
you join a grand procession that
has marched across the sands
of time, marshaled by the
first human being who gazed up
at the magnificent majesty
of a midnight sky and asked
the question, what more can I
know, culminating at this time,
at this place, at this junction
in the space-time continuum
with you and this august
and awe-inspiring assembly
of the academically
accomplished.
For whether you are the first
in your family to attend college
or of the fifth generation
to finish graduate school,
you represent the
collective dreams
of countless of your
comrades and ancestors,
some no longer with
us, who have aspired
for centuries to join with
you in this moment here today.
For you have become the
embodiment of accomplishment,
of drive, of passion, of
perseverance, of ambition,
of strength, and hope.
For in graduating today from
one of history's great wombs
of wondrous ideas,
cradles of creativity,
nursery for Nobel
Laureate, you prepare
to take your place
amongst the great thinkers
and movers of our time.
For indeed, you have ascended
to the top of the Mount Olympus
of the modern academic world.
However, ascending to
the top and becoming
the scholastic and
pedagogical gods and goddesses
of your department
does not signify
that your journey is over.
But to the contrary,
it merely means
that you have a
more excellent view
of a future that is
pregnant with a plenitude
of possibilities.
And so now that
you've come to MIT
and flexed your
magnificent mental muscles,
made mighty by the methodical
mastery of mathematically
menacing, scientifically
sophisticated,
and econometrically intimidating
systems of equations and such--
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
--you have proven that you
are now ready to leave,
for you have
outgrown this place.
When I take time to consider
the significance of this moment,
I am compelled to ponder the
proclamations of the poet who
confessed, "I'm tired of
sailing my little boat far
inside the harbor bar.
I want to go out where the
big ships float, on the deep
where the great ones are.
And should my frail
craft prove too slight
for the waves that sweep
those billows o'er,
I'd rather go down in a stirring
fight than drowse to death
by the sheltered shore."
For in the purest
sense, the poet
captures the essence of
this experience exactly.
For whether you've been here
for one year, or two years,
or three years, or n
years, or n plus 1 years,
in a career that will last
nearly a half-century,
your greatest deeds
have yet to be done.
And you can scarcely
imagine the impact
that you'll have on society
and, indeed, on human history.
And so I encourage you not only
to reflect on and appreciate
the awesomeness of
your contributions thus
far, but also to marvel at the
magnificence of future feats
yet to come.
And so now as you prepare to
set sail for the great world
outside of MIT, it is my
hope that triumph will
be your ever present companion.
May passion fuel
your every endeavor.
May innovation infect
your every invention.
And may a preternatural
propensity for progress
pepper your every project.
And may a blazing torch of
morality light your path.
And as you go
forth, I would urge
you to stand boldly at
the great helm of history
and steer a course such that
future generations will say,
with passionate regard,
that you graduated from MIT,
and the world is a better
place because of it.
And so, you daughters
and sons of MIT,
it is with the greatest
of pride and elation,
heartfelt joy and
awestruck admiration,
and the deepest respect that, on
behalf of the Graduate Student
Council, I bid thee
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
In other words, congratulations
on an outstanding display
of academic magnificence.
[APPLAUSE]
Go ye forth, gentle geniuses--
[LAUGHTER]
--history is waiting
to hear from you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HIDALGO: Good morning.
Everyone here expects
a lot from us.
This is because they think
we have a lot to contribute
to the world, and we do.
But you know what?
I'll bet we expect a
lot more from ourselves,
because we know just
how much we can give.
Just look at what
we've accomplished
in only these past few years.
It's exhausting
to think about it.
We're tired, and the
overall sentiment
is that it feels
so good to be done.
But we aren't finished.
We may be done here at MIT,
but we're only getting started.
We have so much to contribute.
Today can't be the end.
Today is merely a pause,
an opportunity for us
to catch our breath
and reflect on our most
recent accomplishments.
Tomorrow, we'll continue
down our individual paths
and join thousands of others
whose achievements have changed
and will change society forever.
We will become MIT alumni.
And now, as a symbol
of our graduation,
we remove our brass
rats, and we turn
them to face outward at the
world we are about to join.
And as we leave MIT,
we, the Class of 2004,
leave behind our gift
to the Institute.
Dr. Vest, it is a
particular honor
to present this
year's class gift.
Those of us in the Class of
2004 are aware that you, too,
will soon be graduating, moving
on from your current role
as president of MIT.
We salute you for all you've
done for the Institute,
and we wish you
all the best as you
move into the next stage
of your life and career.
At this time, it is my
privilege to present this gift
on behalf of the
graduating Class of 2004.
The HUGE Fund--
HUGE stands for Helping
Undergraduates Gain
Excellence--
will provide
budgetary assistance
to undergraduate students who
require additional funding
for major projects.
This includes additional
research funding
for UROPs, theses, and
other class projects.
So far, 29.3% of the Class of
2004 has raised $31,736.67.
[APPLAUSE]
283 members of our class
have donated thus far,
and we only need seven
more gifts to get to 30%.
So if anyone out there has $10
bills, wave them up in the air,
and we'll be by
with a collection
basket in a few moments.
And last, I would just like
to say, for lack of a better
word, congratulations.
Enjoy today and
enjoy the weather.
[APPLAUSE]
VEST: Thank you, Miss
Hidalgo and Mr. Caulfield.
I am most grateful for
your words and your gifts,
but especially for all that
you and your fellow students
have meant to this
great institution.
I thought long and hard about
what my parting message to you
should be, and it is this.
Thank goodness I
will never again
have to speak after
Erich Caulfield.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Be that as it may,
here we are again,
gathered in Killian Court
to celebrate accomplishment,
heritage, and passage.
It is a major passage
in life for you,
and it is a major
life passage for me.
Together we end
an important phase
of our lives and education
and commence a new chapter.
It may perhaps seem
odd that a community
so dedicated to the future
gathers here wearing
strange and colorful
medieval regalia.
But it is fitting and seemingly
fulfilling of deep human needs
that such rituals take place.
This ritual reminds
us of the continuity
through the ages of our role
in an unbroken, centuries-old
chain of human discovery
and accomplishment.
But above all, it celebrates
your accomplishments
during your student years.
This is not to say that
you have accomplished
the remarkable
feat of graduating
from MIT all on your own.
We are indeed surrounded by
parents, family, friends,
spouses, partners,
and children who
have supported and sustained
you through the years.
You will recognize them
today by the smiles brought
about by their great pride
in your accomplishments
and, no doubt, by a
great sense of relief
to their bank accounts.
Let us then, yet again,
express our deep appreciation
to all who have come
to Cambridge today
to join you in your
Commencement ceremony.
Thank your parents.
[APPLAUSE]
It is also especially
wonderful to see
the babies and
small children who
have come to see their
mothers and fathers graduate.
They, too, are welcome.
And as this ceremony
stretches onward,
I give them special
presidential approval
to comment on the proceedings
at any time and in any manner
they see fit.
Each of the last
13 years, I have
had the honor of
briefly addressing
those gathered for MIT's
Commencement ceremony.
And each year, I have
concluded with the same charge,
the same brief statement
of advice and challenge
to our graduates.
Before I do so yet
again, I want to explain
what the elements of
that charge mean to me
and why I think they
are important for you,
as graduates of
the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
First, you should
ponder the unthinkable.
You each have completed an
intense, rigorous education
with a strong scientific
or quantitative bent.
This is true regardless of the
intellectual field in which you
concentrated and regardless
of the level of degree
you are receiving today.
Armed with this
education and experience,
you have an opportunity
and a capability
to ponder ancient questions
in new ways and also to think,
of course, about new
challenges in new ways.
The world in all
of its dimensions
is evolving at an
ever increasing rate.
You have an unprecedented
opportunity to expand knowledge
and to create wealth and jobs.
At the same time, there
is a tragic expansion
of misery, inhumanity,
and illness in our world.
And it will take new
vision, new thinking,
and new levels of determination
to alleviate these problems
and create a more civil
and humane society.
In other words, to
make a difference
in the condition
of the world, you
must start by pondering
the seemingly unthinkable.
Is it unthinkable that we
might truly be dedicated
to sustainable development?
That is, to using our energy
and material resources
in a way that not only respects
the natural environment,
but offers the
developing world a chance
to reach the same levels
of health and well-being
that we enjoy?
Is it unthinkable
that we should find
ways of cutting
through the increasing
clash of multiple, unmovable
fundamentalist views
and get to the core of
humanity beneath them?
Is it unthinkable
that we could at
last truly bridge,
once and for all,
the racial divides
in this country
and see that our best
hope for the future
rests in pulling together
rather than pulling apart?
That's the first challenge--
think the unthinkable.
A corollary to that is to
question the status quo.
If we are to advance
the condition of society
to create what could be, we
must first question what is.
By definition, advancing
means changing and moving
in more positive, more
productive directions.
The status quo,
therefore, will not
correct the inequities
and ineffectiveness
that are rampant in so many of
America's primary and secondary
schools.
The status quo will not stem
the tide of AIDS in Africa
or vanquish the now
constant threat of terrorism
in every corner of the
world, including our corner.
But as MIT graduates, as
educated men and women,
you have a responsibility
to question
the status quo in an
informed, fact-based manner.
It is your passion and
compassion that will drive you.
But to make a
difference, you also
need clear eyes and
heads and the ability
to objectively analyze the
problems you care about.
That is what can set you apart.
That is what gives
you the opportunity
not only to ponder, but also
to act, to dedicate your lives
and work to important,
worthwhile things.
And when you think about
the things you want to do,
consider the entire world as
your field of opportunity.
In other words,
live in the world
as well as in your own nation.
You are citizens of the world as
well as citizens of the United
States or China or Iran or
Italy or wherever you were born
or gained citizenship.
Each of you shares the Earth
with every other human being.
In this troubled time,
there is a continual tension
between fragmentation
and integration.
The very electronic
communications
that we developed here
at MIT connects us
to each other as never
before in human history.
But simultaneously,
we seem to be
fragmenting into increasingly
more isolated geographical,
economic, political, religious,
or cultural enclaves.
We stare at each
other with suspicion
rather than with welcoming.
We accuse rather
than enlightening.
We raise walls rather than
open doors and open minds.
Integration, mutual respect,
and mutual understanding
must, in the end, win out over
fragmentation and isolation.
But that will not
happen by default.
That will happen only if we
use our minds and our actions
to create a spirit and
a reality of openness.
The cornerstone on which great
American research universities
are built is openness--
openness of our national
boundaries and openness
of our campuses to immigrants,
visitors, students, faculty,
and scholarly colleagues
from all over the world.
MIT, I'm proud to say,
stands as a prime example.
Our MIT Nobel
Laureates were born
in the United States,
Mexico, Germany, Italy,
Japan, and India.
Even our responsibility
to protect
those who live and learn
and work on our campus
and in these United
States, protect them
from the reality of
terrorism, must not
undermine this enriching
and empowering openness.
MIT will continue to work
aggressively and effectively
with our federal government
to develop and implement
sound policies that
will keep our colleges
and our universities open
to international students
and scholars and that will
allow open and productive
scientific communication
and collaboration
among international colleagues.
I ask that each of you join
us in that important mission.
But world citizenship
extends beyond
these important concerns.
It extends to a deep
understanding of the fact
that we all inhabit the same
Earth, that our every action
affects people in far-flung
parts of the world,
and that their actions,
in turn, affect us.
We must not be blind to
evil or to real threats,
and they must be countered.
But they are best countered
by making common cause.
Force has its place, but so
do humility and the forging
of collective efforts
based on shared
values and cultural reality.
Share your talents.
The best way to forge
collective efforts
is to share your talents,
and they are legion.
And you have honed many
of them in important ways
during your days at MIT.
But they are not yours alone.
Society is entrusted to
talented people such as you.
There is a world to feed,
energy to be provided,
natural resources to
be used efficiently
and wisely, human communication
and learning to be improved.
Good health and security need
to be spread across the lands.
And this can only happen by
your sharing your talents.
Commune with all people.
Now, sharing is both
easier and more effective
if you can see yourself as
part of the greater world
community, embracing all
the variety and richness
that the different
cultures have to offer.
Every survey we make of
MIT students and graduates
shows that you greatly
value the diversity
of friends and colleagues
you got to know here.
In all that you do, you
should be steady friends
and bold companions.
Friendship, in both
personal and global sense,
cannot come or go at
the wisp of a moment.
There is both beauty
and practicality
in enduring companionship
and dialogue.
It is on such
enduring friendships
that productive
societies are built.
And it is from
such relationships
as they continue through
the changes of time
and changes of events
that wisdom comes.
But be bold companions as well.
Progress comes
from such boldness
in the context of common
values and aspirations.
And so as you embark on the
next stage of your journey,
I offer this now
traditional charge
to you, the graduates of MIT.
Ponder the unthinkable.
Question the status quo.
Live in the world as well
as in your own nation.
Dream of a better future, but
contribute to the present.
Share your talents.
Commune with all people.
Be steady friends
and bold companions.
Address the truly important
issues of your time.
Be honest in all that you do.
Take your education, your
talent, and your energy
and build a nation and
a world community that
consider knowledge
a gift to be shared,
a healthy planet a
place to be cherished,
and human dignity
and opportunity
fundamental conditions to
be enjoyed by all people.
Men and women of MIT, I wish
you godspeed and the very
best of good fortune.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER: Thank
you, President Vest.
And thank you and Becky for
your dedicated and inspiring
leadership of MIT during
the past 14 years.
[APPLAUSE]
By virtue of the authority
delegated to them
by the Corporation
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
and on the recommendation
of the faculty,
President Vest will now
present the following degrees--
Bachelor of Science, Bachelor
of Science/Master of Science,
Bachelor of Science/Master
of Engineering,
and the advanced
degrees for the School
of Science and Whitaker
College of Health Sciences
and Technology.
Provost Brown will present
the advanced degrees
for the School of
Architecture and Planning,
the School of Engineering, the
School of Humanities, Arts,
and Social Sciences, and for
the Sloan School of Management.
[CHEERS]
Thank you.
As they approach the ramp,
undergraduate degree recipients
will be greeted
by the Chancellor,
the Dean for Student Life,
and the Dean for Graduate
Education--
Undergraduate Education.
Graduate degree recipients will
be greeted by the school deans.
The first graduates
to be recognized
are the class marshals who
are seated on the stage.
[? PRESENTER: ?]
Recognition will now
be given to the officers
of the Class of 2004
and the officers of the
Graduate Student Council who
are seated on the stage.
Maria E. Hidalgo, president
of the Class of 2004,
is awarded the degree
of Bachelor of Science,
as recommended by the Department
of Mechanical Engineering.
Matthew N. Styczynzki,
treasurer of the Class of 2004,
is awarded the degrees
of Bachelor of Science
in Economics and Bachelor
of Science in Mathematics.
R. Erich Caulfield, president
of the Graduate Student Council,
is pursuing the degree
of Doctor of Philosophy.
Michael R. Folkert,
vice president
of the Graduate Student
Council, is pursuing the degree
of Doctor of Philosophy.
Bachelor of Science
diplomas will now
be presented to students in
the School of Architecture
and Planning who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Bachelor of Science in Art
and Design, Carrie A. Brown.
PRESENTER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of
Architecture and Planning
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Master of Architecture--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Planning--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor
of Science diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Engineering
who have completed the specified
degree requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in Civil Engineering,
Anna M. [? Albier. ?]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Architecture Studies--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of Science
in Environmental Engineering
Science--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master
in City Planning--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science as recommended
by the Department of Civil and
Environmental Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of Science
in Mechanical Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Urban Studies and Planning--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Media Arts and Sciences--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Media Technology--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Real Estate Development--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
Without Specification
of Field--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science as Recommended
by the Department of
Mechanical Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Doctor of
Philosophy, with all the rights
and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
science in Materials Science
and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Engineering
who have completed the specified
degree requirements.
Master of Engineering in Civil
and Environmental Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Civil and Environmental
Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science as Recommended
by the Department of Materials
Science and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Archeology
and Materials as Recommended
by the Department of Materials
Science and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Electrical Science
and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Mechanical Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of Science
in Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of
Science in Material Science
and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Engineering
in Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science in
Chemical Engineering Practice--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Ocean Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Naval Architecture
and Marine Engineering, Naval
Construction and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Ocean Systems Management--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Computer Science
and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science in
Aeronautics and Astronautics--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Nuclear Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Engineering
in Biomedical Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of
Engineering in Logistics--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of
Science in Bioengineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Engineering and Management--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Technology and Policy--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of Science
in Chemical Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of
Science in Toxicology--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of
Science in Transportation--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
Without Specification
of Field--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Naval Engineer, Naval
Construction and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science as Recommended
by the Department of
Chemical Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Ocean Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Doctor of
Science, with all the rights
and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of Science
in Aerospace Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Doctor of
Philosophy, with all the rights
and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
Who's that?
I already called him.
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of Science
in Aerospace Engineering
with Information Technology--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of Science
in Nuclear Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor
of Science diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of
Humanities, Arts,
and Social Sciences who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in Economics--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Political Science--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Literature--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor
of Science in Music--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Writing--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Humanities--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of science
in Humanities and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of Science
in Humanities and Science--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of Science
in Linguistics and Philosophy--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of Science
in Comparative Media Studies--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor
of Science diplomas
will now be presented
to students in the Sloan
School of Management who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Bachelor of Science in
Management Science--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of
Humanities, Arts,
and Social Sciences who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Master of Science in
Political Science--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of
Science in Science Writing--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of
Science in Linguistics--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Comparative Media Studies--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Doctor of
Philosophy, with all the rights
and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor
of Science diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Science who
have completed the specified
degree requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in Chemistry--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be presented
to students in the Sloan
School of Management who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Master of Business
Administration, Sloan Fellows--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Biology--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Management, Sloan Fellows--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of
Business Administration--
[READING NAMES]
I said that.
PRESENTER: Say it again.
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science as recommended
by the Department of Biology--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Physics--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Brain and Cognitive
Sciences--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Earth, Atmospheric,
and Planetary Sciences--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Mathematics--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor of
Science in Mathematics
with Computer Science--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Science who
have completed the specified
degree requirements.
Master of Science in Physics--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science in
Brain and Cognitive Sciences--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science in
Earth and Planetary Sciences--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of
Science in Geosystems--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Doctor of
Philosophy, with all the rights
and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
ANNOUNCER: The Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution
and the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
offer joint programs of
education and research
in oceanography and applied
ocean science and engineering.
John W. Farrington, Vice
President for Academic Programs
and Dean at the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution,
is here to participate
with President Vest
in awarding the
following joint degrees--
Doctor of Philosophy, with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto,
Jeffrey A. Gebbie.
[READING NAMES]
Advanced degree
diplomas will now
be presented to students in
the Whitaker College of Health
Sciences and Technology who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Master of Science in Health
Sciences and Technology--
[READING NAMES]
ANNOUNCER: Master of Science
in Medical Informatics--
[READING NAMES]
ANNOUNCER: Doctor of
Science, with all the rights
and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
ANNOUNCER: Doctor of
Philosophy, with all the rights
and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of
Science in Management--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
in Operations Research--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Master of Science
Without Specification
of Field--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Doctor of
Philosophy, with all the rights
and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
[APPLAUSE]
ANNOUNCER: Congratulations.
It's now my pleasure
to introduce
Paula J. Olsiewski
the Chief Marshal,
who will greet the graduates.
Dr. Olsiewski is a member
of the class of 1979
and is currently serving as the
president of the Association
of Alumni and Alumnae of MIT.
Paula?
OLSIEWSKI: Thank you, Dana.
It is my great honor to
recognize the distinguished
members of the 50th-year
reunion Class of 1954--
[APPLAUSE]
--and their very special
class president and dear
mentor of mine, Paul Gray.
[APPLAUSE]
This is the first
time in 44 years
that Paul has not
been on this stage
during commencement as either
a participating faculty member,
chancellor, president,
or chairman.
Congratulations on
your reunion, Paul.
[APPLAUSE]
Now I invite the class
of 1954 to join me
in congratulating all
of the 2004 graduates
and officially welcoming
you into the alumni
family, your infinite
connection to MIT.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER: Thank you, Paula.
The 138th Commencement exercises
of the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology are now concluded.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
A reception will follow on
Kresge Oval in the West Campus
plaza.
And the audience
and graduates are
requested to remain
at their seats
until the stage
assembly has recessed.
And now please join
the MIT Chorallaries
in singing the school song.
[MUSIC - CHORALLARIES, "ARISE
ALL YE OF MIT"]
(SINGING) Arise all ye of
MIT, in loyal fellowship.
The future beckons unto thee,
and life is full and rich.
Arise and raise
your glass up high;
tonight shall ever
be a memory that
will never die, for ye of MIT.
Thy sons and daughters, MIT,
return from far and wide
and gather here once more to
be re-nourished by thy side.
And as we raise our glasses high
to pledge our love for thee,
we join all those of days
gone by in praise of MIT.
[MUSIC - CHORALLARIES, "TAKE ME
BACK TO TECH"]
(SINGING) Oh, I wish that I were
back again at Tech on Boylston
Street, dressed in my dinky
uniform so dapper and so neat.
I'm crazy after calculus;
I never had enough;
t'was hard to be
dragged away so young,
it was horribly awfully tough.
Hurrah for technology,
'ology, 'ology, oh,
glorious old technology,
'ology, 'ology, oh.
Back in the days that
were free from care
in the 'ology varsity
shop, with nothing
to do but to analyze air
in an anemometrical top.
The differentiation of
the trigonmetric powers,
the constant pi
that made me sigh
in those happy days of ours.
Hurrah for technology,
'ology, 'ology, oh.
Oh, glorious old technology,
Take me back on
the special train
to the glorious institute.
I yearn for the inspiration
of the technological toot.
I'd shun the quizzical
physical profs, the chapel,
and all that, but how
I'd love to go again
on a scientific bat.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la,
la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la,
la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
Do, do, do, do, do.
La, la.
Do, do.
Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da.
Oh, M-A-S-S-A-C-H-U-S-E-T-T-S
I-N-S-T-I-T-U-T-E O-F T-E--
and then it's--
C-H-N-O-L-O-G and
Y comes after G.
It's the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
Hey!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - MASS BRASS]